Oh, there we go.
I forgot the music.
My, my, boo!
Oh, jeez, go back to the house.
Gochitin'ama, gochitin'ama.
Sorry, my voice is still recovering.
My voice is still recovering.
Napling Choice Awards.
Can you finish the Breaking Bad recap?
Okay, for those who don't know, I was watching Numi's
stream, too, so.
Nimi...
Nimi asked me the other day, she was like, Can you, she
asked me, I think while I was at Hallmat, and I was like, oh
my gosh, she was like, can you do, I'm gonna do like a
halftime show during my not playing choice awards, could you
do a song for it?
And I was like, whoa, of course!
And she was like, just anything that you're comfortable with
singing, she was like, you could sing, snake eater!
You could sing, you could sing, Leve!
You know, anything!
I know it just turned New Year's for the UK Happy New Year's
But it's not New Year's yet for me But I was like Can I make
it kind of silly?
She was like yeah And so I was like what if I just
summarized Breaking Bad
That's a song
I said season 1 through 3, but actually I kind of stopped
like, oh, oh, the reason I stopped was because I realized I
was like, I was singing it, and then I looked over at the
timer, and it was like, five minutes, and I was like, oh,
no!
I was like, wait!
This is getting too long!
So I stopped where I did.
Yeah.
Happy New Year, everybody!
Oh my gosh!
Can you call us?
I will call you.
Happy New Year!
And...
Wisps!
Happy do you!
Ake-o-me-yu timing is difficult, huh?
But...
Yeah, it's all good.
Crediting you for all the insane Breaking Bad edits showing
up on my Twitter feed now.
I've heard that from multiple people, and I'm not quite
sure.
Will I cause a breaking bad renaissance?
Happy Boo Year!
Also, Kmart, thank you so much for the hot guys there, but
thank you.
Happy early New Year, Minto.
Thank you for always being a beacon of joy and positivity in
my life.
I hope everybody is celebrating well and feeling well.
I woke up with my migraine this morning again, and I was
like, no!
And then I went back to sleep for like two more hours, and I
woke up and it was basically gone!
It's a Christmas miracle!
My new year resolution is to watch Minto and be happy.
It goes hand in hand.
I hope I can keep making you guys happy in 2026!
Wow.
Oh.
Wow, 2026!
Crazy!
Phil, thank you for the walk, I see.
Happy New Year, Minto, and Aibus.
One thing I'm grateful for to 2025 is for introducing me to
your channel.
I hope this year is amazing, and I'm looking forward to all
your hard work individually within the two weeks.
It pay off.
Here's where Freaky Ghost made virtual YouTuber.
Thank you!
Thank you, Phil.
And you went bald.
I'll start watching Breaking Bad again today as well.
Totally forgot it was you who brought it into my mind again.
If someone told me your performance at Nimmy's show was how
I got spoiled on Breaking Bad, I wouldn't have believed
them.
Hey, I only spoiled, like, very early of the show.
I don't know anything that's gonna happen.
I'm on episode 8?
Of...
Whoa, I heard the note of so huge.
Sorry, one second.
I'm on episode 8?
I think of...
of...
Season 3?
You could have plugged your ears if you didn't want
spoilers.
I want to rewatch it now.
I can skip to season 3.
No, you have to see all the Skylar drama.
I didn't even bring her up.
Well, you have to see all the Skylar.
Maybe we could do a watch-along for like, the last couple of
episodes or something.
like of the seat of the like of the whole show because i've
been like kind of going through it
i've been like i've been like zoom zoom zoom zoom zoom thank
you break thank you so much aleiko pigo thank you so much
ducky thank you so much wait oh gosh wait did i miss any
thank you guys for the for the for the gifts and memberships
thank you
Did you watch the whole scene of Skylar singing Happy
Birthday?
I did, and I cringed like crazy.
I was like,
at work?
At front of everybody?
Oh.
Gosh, I forgot about that scene.
And I'm reliving the secondhand cringe again.
Making New Year cute talks!
Thank you for haunting my heart in May 26th.
2026 bringing you the intensive non-stop awesomeness.
Thank you!
Pactai!
And Shane Reynolds, thank you!
Takizo, thank you!
Thank you guys so much!
Oh my gosh!
I'm also in Nimmy's, um, Napling Choice Awards.
Everybody voted.
Even though Loveful was my favorite, as much as I love Ten
Ten, Ten, Go, Go, Go, Go, Go, Go, Go.
I was really happy that everybody voted, not everybody, but
a lot of, that won for Nimi's best cover of 2025, so I'm
really happy.
So, yeah.
I'm in the future.
I'll try my best to wake up for Sloppy Sisters.
Oh, my gosh.
I, you guys, this stream, so I will be on another stream
tonight with Sloppy Sisters.
Me, Doki, Lai Mu, Snuffy.
And it starts at 1 a.m.
my time.
So I'm wondering if I...
I was gonna, like, stream up until the countdown.
Also, my voice is giving out.
I wonder if I should take a nap before...
Baby.
Well, we'll just have our own countdown.
Don't worry about the time down there.
Happy New Year, I mean, thought we did not start 2025, I'm
expecting to watch VTubers let alone.
Discover my Kami, Mg.
Get up, Mature!
Thank you so much.
Now I can't wait to watch what you intend to accomplish next
year.
Thank you for being my goofy Mg's loving ghost, Oshi.
Thank you!
Thank you.
Take that nap, VTuber.
I feel like I should.
I'm already about to y'all.
For those that don't know this game, though, Mint Phantoms,
Freak or Treat.
I, um, me and the team, we made this game, um, together.
Uh, year before, wait, well, no, last year.
It's not 20, 26 just yet.
Last year we made it.
Wait, was it last year?
Yeah, it had to be, because the Christmas update.
So, um...
Yeah, 2024.
Oh my gosh, my brain.
And so, it's based off of a game that I used to play a lot
on the Cartoon Network website that was like a
trick-or-treat game that I loved.
So, I based it off of that.
I really wanted it like that.
And I included some of my friends in there.
I would love to do another update and include more people
because I've made so many more friends now, so...
I think it would be fun.
So, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
Thanks for another great year with you.
We're so stoked to continue to cheer for you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Happy New Year, Minky.
Hope the courthouse Oshikatsu satisfactory.
Oh my gosh, it was more than...
I can't believe you're... You're crazy!
2025 was a lot, but I'm proud of you for making through it.
Save for wait.
The new year will bring you and then set to Yixi.
Hmm.
You're gonna hit the... Hit the ground running.
There's already... Oh my gosh.
I can already think of things in January.
Excited, excited.
Brendan, welcome to Mambuship.
Thank you.
And Brendan.
Pop back later.
I'll see you later.
Puzzle!
Thank you!
Your streams are always such a joy to tune into.
I'm so glad to have found you this year.
You made me know I was so happy.
Thank you.
I really, sorry, don't have such a crazy thing planned for
New Year's this year.
But, um, honestly, I was just kind of like...
I kind of want to just chill with you guys.
I feel like 2025 was so much already.
and I feel like, you know, we could all just hang out.
It doesn't need to be a big spectacle this time.
We can just, you know, we can ring in the new year as a
chill little party.
Spank!
Thank you!
Thank you for the pink.
Looking forward to a new year full of tree frogs and snakes.
Wait!
Wait.
Let's just realize something.
losing the year of the snake.
It won't be the year of the snake anymore.
It's gonna be the year of the haunts!
Yeah!
Haunts!
Now, well, thank you so much!
Thank you for that, guys.
I hope you ain't glad to have found you last year, so
remember the first stream I watched.
Wait, what was the first stream?
You have to tell me now.
Thank you so much!
Recycling a thing you can give someone is your time so you
spoil us whether you admit it or not if you say so when is
the year of the otaku ghost every year every year every year
i could not thank you for the peek come
happy new year
it makes me emotional oh gosh sorry
why am i already crying oh my god No, it just, uh...
Uh...
No, it just makes me really happy seeing you guys here, so
thank you!
That job.
It's just, you know, it's, it's, it's, wait, it's nice, you
know, that, um, that, uh...
I can see so many familiar names at the end of the years.
Thank you!
And thanks for sticking with me throughout the year.
Yeah.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, sorry.
Oh my gosh.
Sorry.
Every time I click out of the thing.
I mean, take a sip in.
Oh, my God.
No, no, no, no.
No more cry.
Oh, my gosh, wait.
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
No, no, no.
I feel the headache coming back.
No, no.
No more cry.
Okay.
Tears be gone.
Okay, we're fine.
Oh, my gosh.
When I cry, I get a headache.
Does anybody else?
Headache be gone.
really sucking in my tears where I'm like
hold hold George!
Happy New Year!
No, thank you guys for all the gift and memberships.
Thank you and all the super chats.
Thank you.
I feel like I'm not going to be able to get to everybody.
Oh my gosh, Gato.
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, 2026.
That's so cute.
So next thing Thank you so much for the peek!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
It's all good, thank you so much for the peek.
Thank you, cars.
Ah, all your New Year's messages, you're gonna make me cry
again.
This is the awesome freak or treat game from last October,
right?
It's the very same.
Cash money robot!
I was watching, I was watching, when I was watching Nimmy's
Napling show, I was like, what are some clips that I would
like?
What are some moments that I think I would highlight
throughout the year?
And I totally thought of you!
I totally thought of that one moment at the end of Journey
where we were like, we were like, who's our partner?
And it just slowly fades in.
Cash money robot.
It was too good.
Yeah, I think it's pink will haunt me forever, pun intended.
Rest in good verse!
Thank you for the pink.
Ladies of the past year and a brighter new one.
I'm stuck at my parents' house for a while, so thank you for
the sanity restoration too.
I'm now the udon guy and swept in the family card games.
Wait, why the udon guy?
Pink.
It's pink.
Was I not wearing this?
very outfit when i said that oh my goodness and that was
halloween that was several months ago and everybody still
quotes it i'm so happy oh i'm glad that my my stupid brain
can make you guys oh yeah my 3d debut gmc5 when dante did
the dance and i got it because it's baked thank you Mr.
McLaughlin, kids.
Thank you.
Can't wait for you to play Ace Combat next year.
Yes, Nan!
Ace Combat soon, soon, soon.
Nixie, thank you!
I feel like I have to play it.
Wait, did they say Ace Combat 8 is coming out?
2026, or was it 2027?
I'm wondering if I should play the series before I move or
not.
That's why I'm wondering.
Or did they even give a...
Oh, 2026!
Okay, so I do gotta...
I gotta...
It's probably towards the end of the year.
Happy New Year from the UK!
Happy New Year!
My birthday is tomorrow in the first and I get a happy
birthday!
Camomil!
Happy birthday!
Boo, boo, boo, boo!
I'm going...
I'm scrolling up and going through everybody's...
Everybody's super chats reading them.
Thank you so much!
Ever thank you!
Chris, thank you.
Ash, and thank you.
Woo-key, thank you.
Sorry, guys.
I was just jorking it.
That was, that was, uh, that was metal, not metal gear.
Um, the, the not metal gear.
Un, unmetal?
Wait, what was it?
Or was it Ghost Babble?
That was Ghost Babble, I think.
Ghost Babble?
That makes more sense.
I was like, I think it was a Metal Gear.
game but it wasn't metal gear one or two so i don't think it
was unmetal yeah it was ghost babble
oh ace gear ghost babble ghost babble is me
ah i can't win against the goomba you guys are remembering
so much so many funny things I liked, I love Countdowns.
Oh, stop!
That one was just me misspeaking.
Fabius, thank you so much for the pick.
May you achieve your goals no matter how difficult they are
because I was ready to do the impossible to help make you
happy.
Happy 2026, thank you.
I wish you all as well.
Happiness, wellness, and love.
Yes, yes, yes.
Lifeline was amazing.
Maybe for you guys.
Oh, so many fun memories.
The Lover on Valentine's is such a great stream.
I love your creative stuff.
Oh, yes!
Glad you liked that one too.
I love coming up with stuff like that.
Just came from Limestream.
I hope you have a great time in your collab later.
Thanks, Copper!
Thank you!
Yeah, we'll see Lyme later.
Was Lifeline really this year?
The bed?
Okay.
In her mouth!
I don't think I could have ever had as much fun as I did
without you in the window.
No!
You know, I know that this year, the past couple of years,
honestly, have been a turbulent times for for a lot of
youtuber stuff um but honestly you know we're still chugging
along i'm still doing my own minto thing my own minto way um
and and you know i i you know obviously we're we're just
streamers at the end of the day most of us at least you know
the people that do stream obviously there's gonna be vtubers
that make videos and everything but um i think also what's
so special is we're we're a little different than regular
like you know regular streamers because i feel we have these
kind of communities that will get together and uh you know i
that's what i really love about being a vtuber is is how how
much i'm able to connect you guys and you know you guys are
able to um have Like watch events or go to events or hang
out with people, meet people.
And I just think that's really special.
So especially when it's very easy to be in a digital world
and feel very lonely.
So I'm just really happy that, you know, I feel very...
That's like the most... That's what gives me the most
satisfaction is when someone will say, because of you or I I
went to this event I would do I can't have it up because of
you things like that so don't get too paranormal I'm
extremely paranormal so
I'm really happy about that and that's what I want to keep
doing for many many more years to come so i will do my best
i think that i booze are the strongest and the nicest and
the most fun and the cutest and everything ever ever
but are we the freakiest that too
Get freakier!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you guys!
Thank you, thank you!
Sorry, I was on my little... I was on my little spiel.
But thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank
you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, fine.
Maybe I will.
Happy pull you!
I went back to find the exact moment I became a membo and I
just lost your worst men in MGS Peacewalker and you were so
caring.
Maybe you went to tear you up.
My men, I care so much about them.
Oh my gosh, I'll be worse when I play Phantom Pen.
And here with Minto was a good year.
Whimsy, thank you so much for the fun, gifted.
Thank you.
Bye, JD.
Thank you so much for the fun, gifted.
It's really crazy how many names come back and all.
I really appreciate it.
You know, you guys probably, you might, you know, it might
be like, she doesn't know I'm here.
But I know this.
I know this.
Glad your voice has gotten better over the year.
Well, it's pretty bad right now, but it's gotten better over
the year.
For sure.
Marco, thank you so much for the podcasting.
Carvadaji!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Wait.
Two bears, thank you!
Happy early New Year, OPA, but whatever, 2026.
Wait, I feel like I'm just reading all your guys' messages.
Chat, moving so fast.
Mint won't notice.
Congratulations.
I boo for life.
Thank you.
Oh, no-no's.
Do we play games here?
There is no such thing as a dumb question.
Oh my gosh, it's already been a half hour, though.
I've just been like, hey, first time chatter here?
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Show.
Oh my gosh, respectable!
Haven't you're still here?
I still can't say your name.
How many years has it been?
I can't say your name at all.
No!
Man.
Someone started...
Oh no!
No chance I'm going.
I could say yippee!
But not yippee for your family.
I hope they're okay.
I gave an opportunity to a YouTuber con.
I rarely got to use any con because I'm so shy.
It's nice.
Did Ace Combat cosplay?
Everybody loved the PNG dog.
I mean, JPEG dog.
Sorry.
I got his name wrong.
Someone was flying so fast, man won't read that I'm actually
gay.
Congratulations!
I'm almost out of my tea already.
You guys are having me up.
Who is PNG dog?
We don't know him.
That's the cousin.
Oh, I wonder if I'll have my...
I wonder if we'll have that outfit ready for Ace Combat 8
then.
I was talking to Barry yesterday before Colab.
And I was telling her that, you know, Sylia is so amazing.
And because she's so amazing, she's also very busy, Sylia
Papa.
And so, I was like, I wonder, I wonder.
to ask you guys too because um part of i really love
consistency so i was like i think i will only stay with
cilia forever and ever as long as i can have her but uh at
the same time i want more than just one outfit a year i
think so if i found if i i still need to talk to cilia about
this obviously but if i found another person not another
rigor that is that cilia i think could work with or um
vouches for or something like that if i had maybe worked
with two people um hopefully i would hope that or i would
aim for that there is not too much difference in how i how i
look but um I would like, like I said, I would like to have
more than one outfit a year or so.
He is PNG original, but fan love to call him JPEG.
Yeah, I know.
That's why I call him PNG, because it feels more proper.
But, you're right, he doesn't move.
It's so funny.
He's just a good boy.
Thank you for the funny years, James Binto.
I look forward to more fun times from both you and Densitoo.
Thank you.
From the gop gop gop gop.
In the blue, I mean the booty shot.
Booty shot.
So many fun games we've done.
Why not webp?
I hope Minto Senpai will notice me, not that I like her or
anything.
Happy New Year!
He's hot too!
Ayami would make the costumes too, right?
Of course!
Ayami forever.
As long as Ayami, Mama will have me.
Yes, yes, yes.
I already have...
My next outfit is planned.
But then I have another one after that.
That is like basically complete.
But obviously I switched the timing on it.
Just don't block her.
I don't!
I don't block her.
I just remember this year, I got dumped.
Mint made it into a clip.
And the eyeballs just kept wishing me good wishes in the
comments, you have an amazing thought.
You were misfortune.
Happy New Year!
Wait, bon, bon, bon, bon, bon, bon, from France!
Hope you are fine and enjoying the New Year's.
love the game and watch overlay too oh thank you i made this
i made this last october for when i debuted the freak
retreat um on stream and and and i've kept it ever since
because i was like i've loved it so much i can't like just
like this this scene i i don't touch it i just like
sometimes I just, I just have it like in my scenes on OBS.
I haven't changed it at all since, since last time.
Actually, wait, I'm gonna move it down a little bit.
Oh, whoops, my bad.
Sorry.
Because you guys, I want you to guys see Nintendo.
Nintendo!
I made it.
I made it in Photoshop.
All me, baby.
How many OBS scenes you got anyway?
Not that many.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine.
Only nine.
But it's because when I do, like, when I do a, like, a
special stream, I make it as, like, a different, what's the
word?
Scene collection.
I still have, like, a...
Wait, what is the Valentine's one?
What is it?
I know some truly disorganized people.
Yeah.
I try to stay organized.
Also, cherry cola.
Thank you!
And my yearly minke tax, please don't send the IBUS on me.
I don't run them.
I don't do have anything to do with them.
Okay.
Shall we play the game, Mom?
This is so...
Wow.
Each costume gives Mint a unique ability.
Use them with space bar to overcome obstacles.
Collect every coin to unlock the next level.
Collect candies for bonus points.
Explore the levels and interact with things that find every
coin and candy.
Starting at the very beginning, baby.
Wait, look at this!
There's so many!
That's me!
Look, look, look.
Lookie, spooky.
Oh wait, that's really weird.
Okay, the reason I didn't play this sooner is because it's
so strange.
Like you?
Hearing my own voice!
It's so weird!
Like I'm not...
Smash, smash!
It's so strange!
And then there's a time limit, you know, so...
Oh my god, the old BGM.
Oh, Maria!
Happy Halloween!
Reggie!
Rime!
I'll see you see Halloween!
I'll see you tonight.
Oh wait, that's a fence.
And look at this side!
I will...
Boo, I must give you a kiss.
Mwah!
Big energy!
Cute fairy costume.
So that's how the game goes.
But people were saying that like the further levels are
pretty difficult.
So...
I'm excited.
Yay.
And then I had lots of help from good team for making all
the music and everything.
Yeah.
It was an ordeal, but it was a lot of fun.
Froggy.
Wait, is this a... Oh, we can go this way.
Hello.
You're in the way.
Ashton!
Bonfire!
How fun!
They got a really good voice actor for this game.
She sounds spot on.
I know, right?
Like, crazy.
And then look!
And look at the...
sneaky boxes?
Who's my star?
It's just so cute.
Everything's so cute.
Big energy!
Dead thing.
I sprinkled my fairy dust on these they're extra special
what's she mean where it comes from what's she mean by that
possibly let's do i know her impressions are crazy no the
three everything is just so cute wait i just noticed these
ones wait that's so cute
yummy the sound effects are trick-or-treat oh by the way i
am inside your home Why did she say that?
Why did she say that to us?
Like, seriously.
What the hell, Berrybug?
I played the game.
This was based on, as a kid.
Happy New Year.
Yeah!
Thank you, Vanilla.
She's weird.
Just ignore her.
I think we should, honestly.
Like, such a weirdo.
Mawikung, mawikung.
Wait, can I get through here?
Am I...
I need to...
I need to smash.
It's like energy.
Where's the smash?
We need to smash.
Where is...
Oh, there's smash.
There's smash.
I just ran right past it.
You gotta smash things because sometimes there will be candy
in there.
Bye, Kim.
Wait.
Smash.
Oh, wait.
Bye, Kim.
Kiss.
Kiss!
Isn't that so nice?
I thought of you guys.
Just kissing you all.
And then you get so happy you go to heaven.
Isn't that so exciting?
This game is bringing back memories of waiting for Flash
Game Solo because my parents had died.
Spooky.
That old, huh?
Like you?
Wait.
Spooky.
There we go.
Here, have some candy.
Like you?
Why'd she say that?
Spooky.
I love all the animations and everything.
Everybody did such a good job.
It's so cute.
I think this is our last guy, no?
Spooky.
Wait, we gotta...
Oh.
No.
We must become...
We must become made!
Makyum.
Tainwaianyu!
Thank you!
Big Minki now!
Thank you for being so uplifting this year!
Of course!
What the heck?
Phoenix bites and fright?
I love Phoenixes.
Minky, Minky, but what?
What is something that you...
Oh!
Trick or treat, you stinky.
Geary!
What is something that you did this year that was, like, a
lot of fun?
Doesn't have to be VTuber related.
Anything, anything.
I just want to hear all the trouble you got into.
Geary, grandma.
Off Kai.
Second trip to Japan.
Went to all-for-one.
Watching Mint.
Come on.
I don't answer.
Korea for the first time.
I've been thinking about, like, doing that.
Did I still have the cruise?
Not cruise, but, like, the boat from Japan to Korea.
I've been thinking.
I was like, I mean, I go to Japan so often.
Maybe...
Oh, my God.
This map is huge.
What was I thinking?
This map is ginormous.
Mint and Ayami collab Assam.
Yeah!
No furniture.
Hazakashi!
See, see!
Okay, we gotta find some.
Ayami will be my guide.
What, in Korea?
Maybe, right?
I don't know.
I've like I've been thinking about Maybe taking a trip to
Korea But I'm scared of going places That I don't know the
language You know So I've never That's why I don't branch
out Matara surrounded by trash Where she belongs
This year was with you and other retubers Ah!
Is that
I'm not in the UK.
Yeah, I don't understand.
I can't understand.
Okay, wait.
Where's like...
Where is anything?
Map too big.
Map scary.
Oh, here we go.
We can start.
Do you guys like the...
What's it called?
The costumes I picked out for everything, y'all.
I was like...
For each effect.
And then we had a Christmas update.
date.
Give me a little hat and the right thing.
It was over a year ago, but I still think of all the time in
planning that went into this game.
Craziness.
Doop, doop, doop, doop.
Take energy.
We got a smash.
Smash.
A gnome.
Wait, I have to become Oh my gosh, get out of the way, Aibu.
Crying, Aibu.
See, there's so many things.
Oh my gosh.
I'm here, Snuffy!
Happy New Year, Happy New Year!
Thank you for the super chat!
Aibu!
Stop being so sad and pathetic.
Stop crying like that.
We gotta smash that for...
a croaky here there's so many tiny details right was there
anything smashing here no can't stop me when i don't or you
guys when i don't start stream on time happy new year from
spain
who's that statue what statue
She hates us.
Wait, there's still so much.
Holy cow.
Oh, wait, yeah.
We have all of Matara.
Does this one break, too?
No.
I don't even know my own game.
To be fair.
Oh, my gosh.
I hear fireworks.
I hear fireworks already.
if did raise your hand if you played this game did you find
it tricky some parts maybe some parts maybe are kind of
tricky right my tower you can play it for free just search
freak or treat you finished it on the first day yeah but
there has been an update trick or treat
I got a package of today from Matara.
You guys, I finally, finally got the goods from...
This is going to sound so bad.
I finally got goods from the podcast that Matara and I did.
Reggie, smash.
Finally.
And I got a package from her.
And I was like looking at, I was like, How the hell did she
package this?
Like energy.
Like what the hell is this packaging?
Mama!
Happy Halloween!
Thank you!
Push, push!
Are those postcards still happening?
You know...
I...
Matara got so busy and I got so busy, still have all of them
uh i have i have a thousand of them signed and then need to
sign a thousand more of like the the last ones matara tried
to find a way to um get the refunds for everybody for the
last two months for it because we were like we are so busy
we're not gonna have time to meet up that many yeah that's
why it was like a that's why it was really difficult for us
to do the last two batches because we ended up getting so
busy and then my hand was like becoming jelly um but so
matara tried to find a way to refund everybody and then
maybe we would give the postcards away at like an event or
something um but since i still have them i would like to
send them out before I move.
So I wanted to talk to Matara again and
have her help me with it.
Or rather, like, see if she's in a position to be able to.
So, it's not that we're like...
It's not that we were like, oh no, we're just gonna, like,
drop this forever.
Like, in the behind the scenes, we've been trying to figure
out what to do.
So...
Yeah, yeah.
Um...
We're just trying to figure out what to do, basically.
I hope nothing shipped to me yet.
No?
We haven't shipped anything.
But yeah.
Can you call us pathetic and sad again?
Why?
Do you really like that?
Well yeah, I do apologize that like the last two months of
the Patreon drawn stuff.
It became pretty overwhelming because it was you know, just
her and I handling everything.
but it's no excuse, obviously.
and I still would like to wait, what am I looking for?
I'm looking for froggy.
I would still like to obviously finish everything.
Where was he?
Over here?
Wait, I think I can fly up here.
Instead.
These walls keep me down.
Nope, that's not froggy.
I love the gnome.
It's so cute.
Wait, there's a trash can here!
Oh my god.
Oh!
I do have Iboos left to shoot.
You're right.
I should get them too.
Mawikung.
Love the gnome.
haircut sticking out of the hat.
What do you mean by that?
Wait, it looks exactly...
Wait, doesn't it...
Doesn't it look exactly at what I'm wearing right now?
Wait a second!
Wait, it looks exactly...
Wait, this is messed up!
There was somebody sad and pathetic up here.
Where are you, poor little eyeball?
Come here.
Just kidding, I got you already.
Someone read the future.
You!
Could have sworn there was one more.
Oh my god, this map is too big.
This map is too big!
Wasn't there one more?
Uh-oh, I have to go smash that too.
I'm seeing double, which is you.
Froggy!
We'll froggy while we're here.
Oh, no!
There he is, there he is, there he is!
Bye, Kyo!
I knew
it.
Come here.
Little baby.
Where are you?
Where is Smash?
Smash?
Smash!
Oh my god, there's another one!
Bye, Kyo!
There was one more.
Okay, good timing.
Smash?
You.
Oh, there's nothing there.
Oh my god.
and then I have to smash up here trash can and then we have
to smash no not smash we froggy hopefully there's something
in this trash can or else I'm going to become the Joker oh
yes big energy yes yes froggy froggy Look how happy they get
when you blow your kisses.
Reggie.
Alright.
To the pond!
I sure hope I didn't forget anything.
You guys can backseat me if you're like, You forgot the
thing!
We're missing two!
Uh-oh, we're missing two candies, guys.
Where?
Where could they be?
There's a trash can behind the lamp.
There's this poor pathetic soul right here.
Alright, that's one.
And this trash can may be.
Is that the one?
Wow.
Hidden.
This is 100% run.
It's more like...
Whoops, I went to the wrong one.
It's more like you can't complete it.
You can't move on unless you 100%.
Smash!
Where was, uh...
Where was my actual outfit, though?
Literally...
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep,
beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep!
You!
Okay!
That means the eye blue is literally the last one!
Wait.
Where did I leave her?
Up here?
Please.
Yes!
Thank you!
We've done it!
My mouse is on the screen.
I know.
It's like a mosquito.
Alright, graveyard gathering.
And then we'll move on to a spooky neighborhood too.
And there's a reward if you complete all of these things.
I remember doing all these first games.
Or the first levels.
I've done all of these ones.
But...
I don't think I did the new levels, so that will be all new
to me.
How many levels are there?
Exactly what you see.
Smash!
Big energy!
When did the new levels come out?
They came out Christmas last year.
Big energy!
So, we're about a year old.
But, you know.
Oh, let's go get...
Let's go get Froggy.
What you say is what you get.
Froggy.
Is she saying big?
What is she saying?
She says big energy.
Oh!
Another somebody that I'm...
Hanging out with tonight.
Here's some candy.
Why she say it like that?
Big energy.
Doki bird.
Like you?
Oh, she put razor blades.
Yeah, she did.
Rise up lights.
Raise up lights.
Rise up.
Rise up lights.
What am I saying?
Razor Blades or Rise up lights?
You'll never know.
What could I be saying?
Who are you making fun of Vicky?
If Vicky were, um...
Australian.
Spooky.
Okay.
Rise up, light!
You can't tell at all!
You can't, you can't.
Don't pretend you can.
She's not...
See, you can't even do...
You can't even pretend that like...
Oh, Vicky is not...
British when she's like so painfully British.
You can't even be like, I thought she was Australian.
There's literally no way you could ever think that.
Also, game devs...
I would like to report harassment.
Niro-sama!
Trick or treat.
Niro-sama.
Where is the smash?
Harassment for what?
For my eyes is all.
Wait, do we have to become fairy?
I think so.
Where was fairy?
Fairy was last seen over here.
Oh.
Smash.
Yeah, I invited a bunch of people.
Big energy to join in my game.
I was really surprised how many people said yes honestly I
was like whoa thanks for being in my game I love the I love
the summoning circle of candy smash smash why would they not
I don't know I mean like if they're busy not interested
Hello!
But it's also fun to see...
Whoops, I just realized I didn't get that one.
It's fun to see how many people I'm like, Oh, my friends!
It's my friends, my friends!
You know?
I think there was nothing up here.
I vaguely remember a few couldn't, but so many became a part
of it anyway.
Yeah!
Now I'm like, who else?
You know, there's so many more people I could have bought.
Which would be nice.
Another update.
Maybe like a...
Maybe we could do...
Because we did a Christmas update.
We could do a summer update.
The spring update?
Summer update?
Something.
Oh, sad, sad.
But...
It was all, you know.
It was all just for fun.
I never, you know.
For things like this.
You kind of just do it because you want to.
Not because it's like a...
I mean, there's no way I can make my money back on this.
It doesn't make any money.
Yeah.
Lifeguard Nimi.
Wait, that would be great for a summer one.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, you're so right.
You're right.
Microtransactions.
Oh my gosh, it could be pay to win.
Send me a super chat right now and I'll give you a cheat
code that you can type in that will help you win the level.
Do we need the froggy again?
Or it will be like you send the super chat.
chat and you get an extra outfit that does everything or
some some evil evil no no no we have not implemented this
system yet you are wasting your money
walk through walls wait that'd be huge what's the chico
thank you oh i i've fooled you into my industrially plan Oh.
Why are you avoiding kisses, huh?
Do you not?
Do you hate me or something?
I'm trying to send a kiss and you're like, no.
Refund!
Spill the tea, give the code.
No!
Paul!
I'll only give you candy if you dress up as a werewolf.
You heard the lady.
Well, I think these are all good.
Okay, we have all the coins.
I need one cat!
Oh, wait.
I think it was that sad, pathetic guy.
The poor, poor guy was our last one.
One cheat code, please.
This is literally a walkthrough, everybody.
Oh, no.
Not again.
My buddy.
I'm not looking for a cheat code.
I just want to super chat.
I think I'm going to turn it.
off super chats i want you guys to i'm gonna hold on i'm
gonna turn off super chats i want you guys for for new years
i want you guys to get something like uh something really
delicious don't send to me i want you guys to to to get
something that you're like this is this is this is a nice
treat for me
cheat codes.
Oh my gosh, I have.
Thank you for the hot guy super.
Thank you.
She's hogging all the cheat codes.
Okay, hold on.
Earn.
I turn off.
where is it?
Super chat.
I understand.
YouTube is so funny about this.
They're like, if you continue, your fans will no longer see
super chat as an option.
and you will no longer earn revenue.
I understand the implications of this action.
Turn off.
There we go.
Thank you, doll.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my gosh, frog for death.
You might be the last super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Don't cry over not being able to send me money.
What is wrong with you?
Free me.
Wait, how did you send that?
How did you just send that?
Oh my gosh.
Zeno Fala!
Thank you so much for the...
See you, bro.
Rise Knight!
Stop!
I can't turn these off.
I can't turn off the memberships.
Do I go, thank you!
Burn and thank you.
Oh my god.
Everything is green.
I do not see.
I close my eyes and I pretend not to see.
But I have to squint a little.
I have to see a little bit.
So that I can play the game.
Wait, I think it's over here.
So much green.
Green women.
Also for anybody who does not like the retro...
overlay you can turn it off if you're like I hate the way
this looks you can turn it off you can be wait wasn't it
here oh I went too far I think oh my gosh thank you wait
unless like you it's not this is it
thank you brother gifted wait they're actually too fast
though
we might have to get that's where the there's one more candy
oh my gosh wait I don't know where smash was I don't know
where to smash oh no no no where is smash super smash brawl
everyone is getting a gift well if you are gifted a
membership and you are interested in going to um going to
buy jazz show well you're in luck because a pre-sale opens
soon i don't remember the dates i'm not gonna say them
because i'm scared i'll give the wrong date but there is
pre-sale for membus only and if you're like oh No, I'm not a
Membu, but I still want to go.
Don't you worry because...
Oh, there it is.
Don't you worry because even if the pre-sale sells out,
there will still be some general tickets that are held.
So, yeah.
Yo, thank you for the gift.
Thank you.
Okay, this should be the last one.
That's my booty!
Yay, we beat the initial game!
Oh yeah, there is a...
There's this wallpaper that you can get.
Thank you, Oimo, for your art.
Thank you for playing our silly little game!
May your Halloween be filled with more treats than tricks!
Happy Halloween!
But we still have more games to play.
We still have neighborhood too.
Which this is all new to me.
I don't remember if they asked me if I should check the game
or not.
I wonder if I lied and said that I did.
I wonder if I was like, yep, looks good.
I wonder.
I mean it does look good Don't make that face Spooky
Foxblade, don't make that face Why are you making that face?
Nice art, I'm glad you like it Yes, it's very good
Thanks for the Breaking Bad summary, Minto Of course For
those who know Breaking Bad, was it a good summary?
Smash!
Do you think I covered some good bits?
Very good.
It was epic.
Oh, I keep trying to go between this car.
Wait, I need to... I need to chill this... I need to get
this car.
Thank you!
Come here, come here.
Come here, baby.
Come here.
Is there anybody else up here?
Solid recap.
It was Freaking epic.
Nome.
Dang it, no no froggy.
I think I need to smash a little bit more.
No I do not.
It's such a good sound effect.
We need to...
Oh, okay.
There is a sad guy down here.
Poor little pathetic fella.
Do you have any fun collabs planned for today?
I bet I do.
You can catch me later.
In five hours?
to 11.
Luna 12.
12 to 11.
In five hours on Doki Bird Channel.
Where we will be in VR chat.
And there might be some special stuff as well.
So you should...
Oh my gosh, I did it again.
You should come watch and hang out with us.
Hey, Ham, thank you!
You have a 2 a.m.
collab?
Well, for me, it's 1 a.m.
But yeah.
I do, yeah.
Alright, we grab him.
We'll go get the key because there's two keys we gotta
unlock.
We must become spooky.
Gosh, Doki, what are you doing up there?
Why are you so...
So out of the way.
Where did I leave the spooky?
Yeah.
Spooky.
Don't fall asleep.
I know.
I'm already like, oh geez.
Am I going to fall asleep during this?
I have to be high energy because it's VR chat.
So I think I'll take a nap.
Don't get sick from VR.
That's another thing I have to not do.
I know.
I was just like...
I'll try and stay for as long as I can.
Obviously, I'd like to stay for the whole collab, but if I
start feeling so bad, it kind of can't be helped, but she
was like, were you just raw-dogging your long streams like
that?
And I was like, yes.
I was.
Okay, there's a lot to smash here.
Okay.
I hear...
Smash!
Um...
Fireworks.
Nice.
Do you guys do fireworks for New Year's?
Make sure the rest of me and Toma...
I will!
Thank you!
That's why I was like...
I could...
Do a stream...
On big energy!
New Year's Day!
but I probably shouldn't.
So, I, don't you worry, you're pretty little head.
Trick or treat.
Oh, by the way, I'm inside your home.
Why did she say that?
Wait, are you guys, don't send donos through super chat.
I mean, streamlabs.
Oh, shoot, the time, the time.
don't celebrate new year's day really sounds kind of
relaxing so much needed rest you guys as well i just want to
say here's some candy i want to say good job getting through
2025 i'm very proud of all of you yes yes yes i'm head
patting you Nadeh, nadeh, nadeh, nadeh, nadeh, nadeh, nadeh,
nadeh, nadeh.
True, we survived.
Yeah!
I always spend New Year's at a relative's place except once.
And now, I, you know, someone, I was talking to a friend
today, and they were like, you're working tonight.
I was like, I was like, why are you working on New Year's
Eve?
That's so silly.
And they were like, you're working tonight.
And I was like, well, I don't feel like I'm working.
I feel like I'm, you know, keeping people company because,
I'm not doing I'm not hanging out with anybody I'm just I'm
at my maid cafe and so obviously there's gonna be other
people too that aren't hanging out with anybody so we're
we're just hanging out if
it was my rotation I'd be working it I'm after all or so you
get probably the big money for working new years right Heck
yeah.
Spooky maze.
Wait, this is really a maze.
Out the way, out the way.
Got paid for New Year's.
Nice.
Do we have some people getting bonuses?
Yeah.
Paid the same!
Ouch.
I'm sorry.
Oops.
I made that guy turn around.
Oh no, they were buddies.
Okay, we're gonna have to smash some.
I got a nice Christmas bonus.
Yippee!
Kiwi.
Trick or treat, you stinky.
I think I need to go smash.
I am unemployed.
That's okay, too.
I'm so work brand It's just, you know It comes from when I
was in Oh well, okay
Wait, was it here?
Yes Smash
How can we buy Minto merch if unemployed?
That should not be your top priority.
Don't say that.
It could make me angry.
I don't know, I just want you guys to eat yummy on a holiday
like this, you know?
Maria!
Trick or treat!
So cute.
Addicted to merch.
Oh my god, that's one time I change over.
There's... I thought I got all the doors!
No!
Truly an angel.
Meow.
Wee.
I'm making cowboy steaks at bacon mac and cheese.
What is a cowboy steak?
What is that?
What makes it different from a regular steak?
Cowboy steak.
Okay, fairy is down here.
Probably will be the last thing we do.
Trick or treat.
It's made of cowboys.
What part of the cowboy?
What part of the cowboy is it made out of?
Oh, this is scary.
Does it have a cowboy hat?
The rump.
Juicy tender.
The boy part.
Alright, let's go get that spooky alley!
It's made from the hat.
I'm getting a whole lot.
Okay, some of you guys have, like, obviously, like, regional
recipes or something.
Because I'm getting all sorts of different answers here.
I guess in some households, they...
Wait, I'm lost?
Regional differences, yeah.
Yeah, clearly.
Wait, oh, God.
Get out of the way!
It's over here.
Yes.
Lots of stakeable parts of the cowboy.
Sounds like it.
I'll have to...
Where could I acquire?
Do I go to my local outback and say, Give me one...
Boy.
Give me it.
How do you cook them?
You ketchup.
Now that sounds like a lot of work.
Gary.
One boy.
Hold the cow.
Okay, this is to fairy.
I think we have one more poor Aibu to kiss.
Yeah.
Guys, this is what would happen if I kissed you.
You would dissolve.
Alright, that should be all of them.
You would dissolve and be so sad.
Worth it It's true, I'm melting I want to dissolve I imagine
it being like the The big energy The, um, what's the words
Like the You know those videos of the raccoons That wash the
That wash their Cotton candy And then they're like Where to
go?
Where to go?
That's what I imagined.
Doodle-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
Poor raccoon.
Yeah, but you have to admit it's pretty funny.
What are we missing?
Okay, we're missing quite a bit of candy candy.
Where?
Hmm.
Oh, here's one.
If I were a candy candy, where would I be?
You would be so sad to dissolve us.
I would!
I would be so sad.
I talked to Garia in my belly.
Wait!
Here's one.
You passed one in the middle.
Other?
Oh!
Now we're missing just one.
Uh-oh.
That's like the worst, and we're almost out of time.
There's one near Geary?
Bee!
Haunted Cemetery.
Whoa.
It really is a cemetery.
Happy New Year, Minto!
Happy New Year!
What thing?
Oh my gosh, you guys.
Because I was gone for so much of like...
Kiwawa!
I think she was one of the people I tried initially to get.
Triven says, thank you!
Thank you for always haunting everyone bringing joy and
laughter through your stream singing and other activities.
Riding Idol made the new year.
Bring more fun opportunities in Giant Evenbrother.
Gamba Minto!
Thank you!
It's so funny.
Because usually you always donate at like the end of the
stream.
And I appreciate it so much.
And I'm just like, oh.
There's the Tri-Princess donation.
Feels like the end of the stream.
I don't mean that in a way to be like.
Okay, you gotta keep it up.
It's just kind of like a...
Oh yeah.
There it is.
Smash!
Spooky.
But um, because I was gone for like the...
The, um...
Holidays and stuff.
One thing I didn't get...
Was a pumpkin pie.
I didn't get pumpkin pie.
And, and while I was in Japan, one thing I was desperately
trying to find, was just some dang gingerbread.
I just want...
They don't have any gingerbread.
So if anybody is in Japan and knows where to get
gingerbread, please tell me.
I think it's still time, right, for me to be able to get
pumpkin pie?
Probably right.
I went to a Christmas market and I searched everywhere and
could not find any...
any gingerbread.
Do you like gingerbread?
Yes!
Oh my gosh, I love ginger snaps!
And I love ginger snaps the most with milk.
Smash.
It's... Oh wait.
Let's go get this guy.
I love me a ginger snap with the milk.
So good.
Reggie.
Hmm.
Best combo for sure.
I agree.
They're great with chai too.
I can believe that.
100%.
I can definitely believe that.
Ginger chew candies.
Raggy.
Usually ginger is like kind of too...
It's too spicy for me.
Let's hear Wawa.
Merry Kitty Christmas.
Smash.
I remember now.
I was like, Kiwawa, do you want to be in my Halloween game?
And she sent her audio...
Through like Discord.
Wait, where's the last coin?
Oh, there it is.
So the quality is kind of funny.
Hot dog indeed.
Uh-oh.
We're missing the candy candy.
Oh, wait.
I'm too good.
Josh, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank
you, thank you, thank you.
Keep up, we're almost done.
Wait, we have one more!
And then we can play Mind Sweeper.
She's just too good at her own game.
I know.
This is, this is the, this is the true um, tutorial.
Oh, getting this game done, baby.
Mama, happy Halloween!
Push, push, push, push.
Smash!
No Christmas levels.
Well, they were like Christmas fad.
But we did add extra levels.
Yeah, yeah.
Does it smash?
No.
I think I tried that before too, even.
yeah they were christmas-fied a little bit i got my hat and
and such yeah but ultimately it's i mean it's a halloween
game right we gotta keep it and then yes i added henya merry
christmas dayo oh my gosh if i can add nimi it will be like
so perfect on my oshi to Kiwawa, Henya, and Nemi.
Oh!
I need to become spooky again.
I don't watch Twitch very often.
So when she started cross-streaming, I was like...
Spooky!
Oh my god, finally.
Saba and Dubi?
Oh yeah!
Dubi would be really great to add too!
Yeah!
And Saba.
I haven't been able to talk to her so much.
Just a little bit.
She's very, very nice.
Sabah is.
I hope her health is okay.
I saw that she said she would be streaming somewhere come
2026.
So I'm excited about that.
Because, I don't know, there's just something so relaxing
about watching her and her voice and everything.
So I really like watching her.
Phoebe and Vicky!
Oh my gosh, that's a total given!
Of course.
You see, like I said, there's so many more people I can add
now.
Oh.
I'm excited, like, to be able to add so many more people.
Okay, that's for the eyeball.
Happy Halloween!
I sprinkled my fairy dust on these, so they're extra
special.
Extra special.
Oh, that's where it comes from.
Mm-mm.
Got beasties!
Oh my gosh.
Wait, I'm gonna have to bake like...
It's gonna be like a crazy, crazy game.
Where?
Where was I getting?
What was I getting?
I don't remember.
Wait.
Oh, I...
Oh yeah, looky!
I was gonna spooky.
Because there was one thing to unlock and then we can
become...
Regular Minto I like you Ad German I saw that guy, yeah Of
course, why would he not be in this game?
Of course, of course!
Eat Eat Laugh and grow fat Invite in sim You know, so long
ago I like emailed him I was like, hey I know you don't
really like no VTubers but like I really like your streams
Would you be interested in like a collab where You teach me
and like some other People how to play Phasmophobia
Happy New Year looking forward to the next 20 20 26
Obviously Yes He never responded Actually I don't know if he
responded.
Maybe he did.
Reggie.
Like you?
I think we have one more guy that kiss.
Yeah, I'm just going to invite every streamer ever.
It'll be the ultimate streamer Halloween candy.
Ultimate Halloween candy searching game.
Done like no one has ever done before.
It will be the smash of streamer Halloween candy games.
Wait, how do I get over there?
Every single streamer ever will be there.
I'll only give you candy if you dress up as a werewolf.
Big energy.
She's so real for that.
What could go wrong?
Surely none of the people that would be invited would ever,
ever get cancelled.
Ever.
Not on my watch.
I mean, they're in a steamed game freak retreat.
They must keep up appearances.
They can't just be going off willy-nilly.
Ashton!
We have some candy.
You can have the green one.
Woohoo!
Oh my gosh, wait, we actually did it.
I thought this would take some time.
so much longer oh oh he oh my god christmas neighborhood oh
who
complained there was no christmas oh
sorry for these ones though i did not get a custom bgm sorry
i did not get a custom bgm for these though
christmas christmas wait oh my gosh you Guys, I offer you so
much content.
Do I not?
Look at this.
Crazy.
She might be the best to ever do it.
So much content.
Oh, for free.
Free DLC.
Look at the eyeball with the Santa hat.
It's too cute.
There's Henya, yeah.
We'll go steal.
Wait.
And then...
Was it here?
No.
Game of...
Yeah, where was my nomination for the Game of Words?
I have one...
Where was my nomination?
Big energy!
It would be Expedition 33.
Truly!
Don't...
We could just say don't knock it till you try.
There's always next year.
well do they I mean Elden Ring DLC got nominated so why
couldn't my DLC be
nominated lost to Expedition 33 how could this happen how
could this happen wait oh did I mess up I thought there was
more smash oh there's no more smash we gotta go back to
fairy
Rigged!
What do?
I've only heard about Expedition 33 that people be crying
about it.
Oh, there was this smash!
That's right!
But I had to open this first.
Uh-oh, I messed up again.
Except I know where it is though.
I know where to smash.
I know.
It gets emotional, does it?
It does look fun, but it's also like the type of game that
I'm...
I don't know.
It's not really my type.
Maybe.
Big energy.
Smash.
But it might be fun.
Big energy.
Smash.
Very good game.
Is it long?
I'm not so into turn-based stuff.
That's how I feel.
So that's why I'm like, I don't know.
Might not be like for me, probably.
It's pretty long.
Devs?
Do you see that on the house?
30, 40 hours?
Dang.
Romance is in the air.
Were they under the mistletoe, you think?
Froggy streets.
I think the music I chose for this is pretty cute still
though.
I still think it's kind of cute.
I'm not gonna lie.
You like the music?
It's extremely Christmas, isn't it?
What was it, wasn't it?
Yeah, we got everything here.
See you!
Froggy!
That's me right now.
I see Fauna.
I...
Mayoshi.
Man.
Wait!
I did include Duby!
I thought I did!
Christmas time is here.
Merry Christmas!
I was like, wait a second, though.
I thought I included Duby.
It's been a whole Wow you guys There's been so much going on
in the year My own game is surprising me Isn't that so fun?
It's also like a good little I mean It's also I feel Good
time capsule for For things to Roll the coaster over here
For real.
It feels like, oh, I can't even believe it's only been one
year from so many things.
Big energy.
That's what kind of blows my mind where I'm like, whoa.
Good way to reflect on the past year.
Yeah, even though I mean this is older, but that doesn't
matter.
It's fine, whatever.
Kiwawa's so cute.
She's so cute and ganky.
Physically, it's been one year, mentally like five.
So true!
Five words, five.
Oh!
I like how Kiwawa's outside.
Of KFP.
Big energy!
What did I miss?
Only just one.
Oh, I think there was a Smash.
Smash!
Can't wait!
Thank you!
Retweeted that stupid pin asset I made because the postcard
talk reminded me.
Wait, there's still more.
Jimmy!
Thank you for the gift!
Thank you!
Wait, oh my gosh, I'm gonna run out of time.
Say more!
Thank you for the 2026!
Agnes, thank you!
I mostly watch your clips or vlogs.
fun person to listen to, you are passionate about your craft
and surround by great talents.
Have a great 2026 and join with both family, friends, and
coworkers.
Jaguar.
That's actually still kind of blew my mind that it's not
pronounced Jaguar.
Wait, what did I miss?
It is kind of blown my mind that it's not pronounced Jaguar.
I still say Jaguar.
Jaguar.
Big energy.
What did I miss you guys?
Uh-uh.
Oh!
I missed a sad boy.
YAHOO Forest Lake Oh, yes
Poor lonely eye Oh, you're not a key Poor lonely eye, boo So
sad
Hey, quit crying Go somewhere else Jelly toast Thank you so
much for the 10 kids today Thank you!
Do you guys see many VTuber references that you...
You're like, you point at the screen, you're Leonardo
DiCaprio?
I understand that!
Trick or treat!
Acceptance Christmas!
Christmas style.
Wait, I think I forgot the house.
Doki is around.
She's somewhere.
Oh!
There's a good... So I did a I did a contest where I was
just like, you know, when I was adding more people to to the
game, I did like a, you know, just kind of post here.
And I'll choose somebody at random.
like a smaller like indie vtuber to be featured in my game
and uh i thought it was like i was like oh my gosh this is
so perfect because um she was a she was a vtuber who was
like her name was i idoloo and i was like oh you love idols
too so i was like this is so perfect i haven't heard i I
haven't seen her around.
I hope all is well.
Wait.
Smash.
Ugh.
Reggie.
Wait, I think I still need to smash.
Yeah, so that's why she's in the game.
Wait, I think I got all the smash.
Reggie.
Yeah, how is she doing good?
I haven't talked to her at all.
It's okay.
Thank you.
Oh, I think we need to go back to fairy.
Fairy down here.
Big fish.
Spooky.
Spooky?
Fairy.
Right here.
Big energy.
We do be flying.
It's like you were in charge of the development?
Yeah, I mean, it was my creative idea, so I guess so.
Cute!
Oh.
Smash!
That's it.
P-san.
But I have no game development brain so most of that was
left up to the team.
I kind of was just like, guys, here's my idea.
Can we do this?
And they were like, makashete, me too.
And I said, thank you!
Uh, nihonko?
That's exactly how the whole conversation went.
You eat Japanese?
No, I don't know.
No, I said I don't understand Japanese.
I don't understand it.
No questions asked.
No, I asked many questions.
But it would be great to get the team back together to do
some more.
It's not a jailbird!
To do more stuff in the game.
Snuffers!
Merry Christmas.
The full sloppy sister crew is about.
Snuffy.
This map is pretty big too.
Smash.
Do I need to smash in there?
Oh, maybe we're fine.
Oh wait, I need the froggy.
Directed by...
Exactly.
A hundred percent.
Feliz Ao Nuevo!
Buenas...
Buenas noches!
Yeah!
Uh...
What was I missed?
Oh, fairy.
Subkoshi, tabemash.
No, tabemasen, tabemasen.
Tabemasen!
Egg energy!
Did I say everything right?
Did I say it right?
Where's my pronunciation?
Way bien?
Yeah, it was good.
Yeah.
Wait, I'm missing two.
Rock roll.
Reggie!
Hehehehe.
Uh-oh.
Team?
I'm lost.
Team, we need two more candies.
Team, we're gonna run out of time.
Oh, I found them.
Gang, we might be lost.
Never.
Never lost.
Alright!
Four more levels.
I love how this one is just parking lot.
I think they ran out of names.
We're like, guys, Merry Christmas at the parking lot.
The most festive place.
Okay, but parking lots you gotta be at.
For...
You park to go get presents.
Everybody knows that.
Short, sweet, to the point.
Wait, why did I start off as a skelly if I need to?
Wait, was there... Did you guys see it?
A place to open?
I didn't.
Smash!
Trick or trunk to buy Christmas?
Look at, we're seriously in the parking lot.
How festive.
We joke, but some people are celebrating New Year's right
now in the parking lot.
So, who are we to judge?
Poppin' in to wish me a happy new year!
Happy new year!
One thing, I want to talk a little bit about my goals for
new year.
I have...
This is I, I, go in.
Say, Merry Christmas!
Her voice is so cute.
Um...
What did I write down?
I wrote down some stuff.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Um, one thing that I have not done in quite a long time, and
some of it has been because of my voice.
Looky.
Some of it has been because, excuse me, has been because
just, I don't know, I get so tired.
But I want to bring back more.
post game yapping just where I'm like you know I finish a
game and then I'm like okay we're gonna talk now for long
time oh my god get out of the way Aibu please Aibu Aibu
please Aibu how did I get out of here how did I get past you
so I'm not very I don't feel like I'm very confident in
doing like full Zatsudan stream full like chatting streams
so I feel like I can instead supplement with more yapping
post game sometimes give sometimes I just game until I'm
like literally so like I can give no more and so that's when
I'm like okay I'm tired I'm gonna go I'm gonna go rest but
that's one of my goals is to bring that back and one thing I
want to do more are like more freebies Um, you know, just in
general, like also membership stuff, like I want to start
doing, um, maybe some like meetups in VR chat, like kind of
like a meet and greet.
If you can't get a meet and greet, um, smash at, wait, what
am I missing?
Oh, here.
If you can't get a meet and greet, if you can't go to a
convention or something, maybe one in VR chat or something
like that.
I don't want to commit entirely to doing like the monthly
wallpapers.
Just yet.
Because it's a lot to sometimes...
I can't keep track of who I contact with artists sometimes.
But that's another thing.
Maybe I'll just offload that to Densa to staff.
But yeah.
And yeah, those are some more things that I want to do.
Maybe some, like, also things that you can, like, what's the
word?
Like, freebies that you can print out, like, 3D printable
things, or I did the stickers for members not too long ago.
I want to do more things like that.
So, yeah.
That's another thing that I had in mind.
Nexi!
Get donated to.
Stop it.
Halloween!
I sprinkled my fairy dust on these so they're extra special.
I miss Halloween!
Let me ask where it comes from.
Oh my god, wait, the eyeball post is too cute.
Where's anything to unlock?
I miss Halloween.
Me too.
Yeah.
I miss Halloween.
Gingerbread.
I want gingerbread.
If...
Oh my gosh, wait.
You guys, I think stores will be closed tomorrow.
I can't get...
I was like, oh, I'm gonna get pumpkin pie tomorrow.
I can't get it if the stores are closed.
Rip my chungus live.
After live.
Well, I actually, you know, rip in general.
You can say rip to me, but I'm a ghost.
So it's kind of like telling me to die.
You're like, rest in peace.
What, you want me to go away?
So rude.
Just, don't, you can't just tell me that.
Rest in misery?
Well, it's more like, just don't say it at all.
You can just say...
Spooky.
You can say...
You know what?
If you have nothing nice to say, you don't need to say
anything at all.
Oopsie poopsie.
Perfect.
Merry Christmas.
Merry Christmas, Nuffie!
I'll see you in a few hours.
I think I need to smash.
No!
I need to moly kill me.
Loopsie poopsie.
Yeah, loopsie poopsie!
Oh, I do need to smash, though.
You could say rest in pizza.
Rest in pepperoni.
Because then it's like, oh, yeah.
I don't really like pepperoni, though.
I'm offended by that.
Never mind.
Don't say that to me.
In pizza.
Rest in pizza.
Rest in pineapple.
So...
Wait, where's a fairy?
Besides Maya.
There it is.
Big energy.
Hot soup.
Look, it's corn soup, everybody.
Corn soup.
I'm going to have that after stream.
Do you guys ever think about, like...
Oh, wait.
We got to kiss you.
Do you guys ever try to, like, plan your final meal of the
year?
I try to do that.
Um, and after I talked about those pizza rolls on stream, I
was like, I think I'm going to make that my final food of
the year.
Big energy.
And so I made them today.
But I made them for lunch.
So I was like, wait, I'm going to have to eat something else
in the day.
What do I eat?
And so I think I will have corn soup as my final food of
2025.
I thought you were going to stop at final meal.
Like a single person said yes.
Think about it.
Like, you end the year with a good food and then you are
starting the next year with something delicious in your
tummy and on your taste buds and you're like, yeah!
I'm getting jolly bee as my last meal.
You do?
Okay, machi.
Machi my man.
Not really.
I never think about it.
Well, I think a good food is like the cure to anything.
If you're having a bad day, Just get something yummy.
I think is a great plan.
Oh my gosh, sometimes I feel like I'm getting Hansel and
Gretel with collecting these candies like this.
I had Popeyes.
I don't think I've ever had a Popeyes.
What is your best biscuit?
Like, what is your, like, you know how everyone was like,
there was, what was the other, there was like those biscuit
wars.
Um...
Carbonara!
Wait, can I come over?
Can I pizzazz?
Can I have it by, please?
Red lobster.
Those are the cheddar biscuits, right?
I've never had those either.
Bojangles.
Popeye's biscuits are my fave.
No, please!
Turn back around!
Oh my god.
Okay, I don't think we're going to be able to get that until
we kiss them.
They're two in the way.
Happy early New Year's.
Happy New Year!
Oh my gosh.
My aim.
Smash.
Like you.
Chicken and waffles.
I love...
Oh my gosh, I'm so obsessed with chicken and waffles.
But I don't know ever where to get them.
I always just kind of make them myself.
There's like something, I don't know.
Like, there used to be a place that was, unfortunately moved
away from it, and then after I moved, they closed down.
So I can't even, I can't even go anymore.
But they made the most amazing chicken and waffles ever.
You can get them at IHOP sometimes.
No kidding.
you were keeping them in business clearly they were so good
i'm telling you and it was a local place so it wasn't like a
chain or anything why is this on the ground is that liz's uh
sword i just noticed
i've never had the chicken and waffles combo it's i'm a huge
sweet savory fan so for me it's like perfect but if you
don't like sweet and savory you can pass probably but
yeah i love me some chicken waffles
it's a great mix and that's why i like that's why i like
pineapple on pizza i there i said it Sweet and savory.
It's so good.
It's a great combo.
Where is Skelly?
There it is.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, how do I say your name?
Amphetamine overdose.
Thank you so much for the fifth day gift.
Thank you.
Big energy.
Thank you so much.
some more though.
Hot dog!
Organizer thank you!
I ate a pizza.
Also, don't worry.
Oh, I ate a pizza.
Don't worry.
Also, hot dog gotcha.
You got the gotcha!
Spooky.
Smash.
You got the good- the goodcha.
You got the goodcha!
I
love the way she says it.
Merry Christmas.
Sorry for my brand, everybody.
Sorry, I don't know how to properly say things.
Sorry.
I'm sorry for the way that I am.
I apologize.
I apologize for how I am.
It's your charm point.
I feel like I've gotten so worse though.
You guys don't think so?
That I've gotten pretty bad with speaking?
You would think the more I public speak, the better.
But I think I've just regressed.
Merry Kikiri Christmas.
Smash Kind of yeah Oh Big energy Smash Oh Big energy
Snowflake Yahoo I think you've gotten better use Stumble
less over long words I guess that's true
It's time for our final...
Final level!
This is it!
The final, final level of Freak Orchard.
I agree.
Say Merry Christmas!
Merry Christmas!
The tree is so cute.
Let's get that 50th game, baby.
Oh my gosh, wait!
You're right, I forgot why I was doing this.
You're so right!
This is gonna be my 50th game, you guys!
Oh my god!
Sugar tree, you stinky!
Sorry.
shack it's the merch shack she's gonna do it I'm gonna
complete the game look at the three Minto wait I wonder I
should ask them if they can like make one one like lilac why
am I so bright oh Oh, I forgot I turned on the thing.
Wait, what if I do this?
Wait, can I go even brighter?
Hot dog.
Hot dog indeed.
Rikti, thank you for this spooky donut.
I'm getting something tasty to eat from my favorite maid.
Spaghetti, please.
I'm sorry, I only serve spaghetti at midnight.
So sorry, spaghetti comes at midnight.
It's like my policy.
So I have this...
I will give you candy if you dress up as a werewolf.
I have this company called Spaghetti Comes at Midnight.
And that's all we do.
It's exactly at midnight.
You can order your spaghetti.
Not 12... not 1159.
Not 1201.
Ho ho ho ho!
Christmas time is here.
This gotta be exactly on the dot 12.
Spooky.
And we'll deliver the spaghetti the following midnight.
You hear me?
My screen is gonna have a high contrast, mint shaped
imprint.
That sounds like a scam?
That's annoying?
What do you mean?
We're very exclusive.
Oh, sorry.
We're a very exclusive and, like, sought-after spaghetti
making company.
You can't just, you know.
Sorry that we don't cater to your needs, but this is just
how the world works, baby.
I forgot some over here.
Sad.
High-end spaghetti.
Yes, our clientele, they understand everything that goes
into like this.
Happy Halloween!
I sprinkled my fairy dust on these so they're extra special.
Into our company.
Please understand.
It's just business.
I booze understand.
That's what I'm saying!
That's exactly what I'm saying.
This is a huge map.
Final level, baby.
Can I pay extra for chicken parm?
No, no, you get it as we make it.
That's how we only make it one way.
Regular spaghetti.
Sandra, welcome to Membuship.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my gosh, isn't that so exciting?
If you joined Membuship for the first time today, in one
year, if you stick around, you will be you will in on new
years you can become a one-year member where did I put the
key I'm getting a lot oh here it is spooky spooky I I'm kind
of obsessed with like people that time their their stuff for
new years apparently did you guys see that there's like some
there's a showing there's a showing of Zootopia in China
that that they time they time the movie to where Nick says I
love you partner to Judy at exactly at midnight isn't that
insane Happy Halloween!
Happy Halloween!
Push, push, mama, push, push.
You're joking.
No, I wish I were.
It's kind of awesome though.
And then there are people that will like, time their roller
coasters.
So they'll time trying to get on a roller coaster and
exactly fill his vault.
Superchat time!
No Superchat though.
Honestly, stream labs are better.
because you're not giving money to YouTube.
Big energy.
So thank you.
Thank you for not giving money to YouTube.
Naughty YouTube.
Uh-oh.
No!
But what was I saying?
Oh yeah, people will time their roller coasters.
They'll get on roller coasters and time it so that the first
drop is on the new year.
That also seems... I want to try that.
That seems exciting.
Big energy.
Big energy!
Spooky!
Happy Halloween!
Slavic fellow, thank you so much for the 20 gift!
Trick or treat!
Thank you!
I think...
There we go.
Here.
Got a feeling.
There was something I needed to open.
Oh my gosh, there's so many.
I need to find a way to cure these poor lonely Aibu.
And welcome to Membushet!
Thank you!
This map is humongous you guys.
Look at the time.
We've barely...
Who's hoarding all this stuff here?
Oh, stuffy.
Is lime in this game?
Yeah.
Merry Christmas!
Raccoon moment.
Truly smash.
That would have been so easy to miss that.
I think this level is going to be hard, you guys.
Dio.
Is there anything...
I know sometimes people will time movies to certain things.
Oh, let's go get that trash can real quick.
Smoothie.
Some people will time movies to certain things for midnight.
Is there anything you guys have, like, tried to time before?
Wait.
What if we timed this stream?
What if, okay, what if you timed the stream to where if you
start watching this stream at so many minutes and so many
seconds in, I will say happy new year.
Wouldn't that be so crazy?
Spider-Man 2 and he says Pizza time at midnight Coco Welcome
to a membership Thank you
Do be trying
Not fair yet I think he's the only guy around here Or maybe
there's one more Let's go check
guy.
Thank you for the vibe get it!
You have to end stream before midnight then.
Yeah, I think I have to because I'm getting sleepy.
Oh.
I was talking with Phoebe yesterday.
I was just like, she was like, do you want to try?
She's like, I always try to stay up for the sunrise, the
first sunrise.
And I've tried to do that before too.
I was like, yeah, I've tried that before.
She's like, you want to do it together tomorrow?
when I was like, I don't think I'll make it.
Maybe though, I might make it.
I might get so excited because of, Merry Christmas.
I might get so excited because of the collab.
I'm excited.
I'm, like, I'm all, like, buzzed from it.
I'm like, Happy Halloween.
It's hard for me to stream late because I get, even though
I'm, like, yawning and I'm like, oh, guys, I'm so sleepy.
Oh, Like, like right now, I will, I end stream and I'm like
so like...
It's hard for me to...
For me to sleep after.
I may seem Eepy, but then I'm like awake for so much longer.
Okay, we got Duby over here.
Really?
Thank you so much for the...
Oh, I've kept going!
Oh wait, there's some things I need to smash.
Oh shoot.
I always yawn when I'm not sleepy.
Me too!
I don't know why.
There's a fairy here.
There's a maid here.
No smash.
Smash here.
Happy late New Year, Minto.
You're early for me!
I think there's one.
In here.
I guess I could have done this.
Push them!
Here, got some candy.
Thank you.
Oh.
You can have the green ones.
In here, there's smash.
Smash.
Okay, time to smash.
What time is it for you?
That time right there.
9-18.
Because I...
My maid cafe operates It's in the EST time zone, even though
I'm virtual Akihabara.
I gotta get, I haven't adjusted my clock, so I just, I just
stay in EST.
Oh, I was here.
She's worldwide!
Oops, smash.
More smash.
Virtual world time is funky like that.
Yeah, exactly.
It's kind of, you know.
It's all wonky.
Oh my god, there were none in here.
Were there anything else over here?
I think I got everything, though.
Uh-oh, guys.
I passed a candy?
I walked past one.
I went past it twice now.
Wait, was it over here?
My VTuber is blind.
Oh, I see it.
And then I need to go down here towards Ashton.
Goes over here.
Oh.
Look what they're specialized.
My brand.
Uh-oh, wait.
Oh no, I want to...
I'm stuck.
Wait, maybe I go around this way.
I can make it.
Happy New Year.
What are some of your New Year resolutions, your goals?
Was there anything that you wanted to do this year and ended
up being lazy?
More gym!
Oh boy.
Big energy.
Wait, I have to go down this way.
Be less lazy.
Good egg smoking!
I can help with that.
If we need me to.
I can be of assistance.
I've done it before.
Nice.
My garbage candy.
Yeah, I'm going to be trying to draw more.
That's one of my goals.
Start the Appalachian Trail.
How long is it?
The Appalachian Trail.
Guys, I don't know.
We still have a lot of coins left, and I have no idea where
I haven't checked.
Uh-oh.
Check the water.
It's like a A month long?
What?
I thought it was like...
I thought it was like a week.
A whole month.
I don't think I missed talking to somebody.
I need to find Frogbert, but I don't know where I put him.
Oh gosh.
Where did I put Frogbert?
Uh-oh.
Three, wait, three to six months?
East Coast.
Pretty sure I talked to Doki, no?
Frogbird!
I remember you left a frogbird at the right side.
Alright.
Orbital Vagabond, I'm trusting you.
I'm trusting you.
I'll go talk to Doki anyway, because we're right here.
That's a fairy.
Smash!
Yep, we talked to Doki.
It's among the barrels.
Wow, amazing memory.
Froggy.
Check out more of the water.
Oh, very bug!
You're on an island!
Kick or cheat.
I'm inside your hole.
We still have 26 minutes remaining.
That's crazy.
No!
I don't want to let...
Wait, here, I'll...
I'm going to go get some more water and you guys can watch
this, okay?
Or...
Do you want to play the game yourself and then you get the
reward yourself?
Play it.
Okay, I'm going to get more water then and you guys can
watch.
Boo!
It is I, Minto, the Christmas bear!
And if you are seeing this video, that means you completed
Freak or Treat!
Or the additional Christmas levels.
I don't know what to call that part.
Is it still Freak or Treat?
Maybe we can call it Jingle Freaks.
It's a work in progress.
Anyway, you probably already got the other gift from the
Halloween levels if you got this far.
I wanted to come personally, and thank you for not only
playing my game, but also taking the time to finish it.
So, thank you!
I hope some of the levels didn't give you too much trouble.
I know those final candies can be a little tricky sometimes,
but I hope you have a super duper, super Merry Christmas.
and a happy Halloween!
I hope we can spend many, many more holidays together, and I
will catch you later.
Ew.
In your walls.
Anyway, thank you so much.
Merry Christmas.
Bye-bye!
Bye!
Yay!
Wait!
I get to do it!
I get to put it!
Hold on, let me... let me... I had to click out so I'm gonna
put it onto my own BGM.
We'll do...
50 games.
My completed list.
I must put it on.
12, 31, 2025.
Freak or treat.
Give me a second.
I'll show you guys my list.
One second, one second.
There it is.
Wait, hold on.
I'm gonna put it underneath.
There we go.
Oh, wait, but then it blocks off some of it.
I can make it smaller.
Wait, hold on.
There we go.
Wait.
Oh, where'd it go?
Wait, where'd it go?
How to do that?
Wait, do you guys see it?
Where'd it go?
No, yeah, but you see it...
You see it now?
Do you see it here?
That's so weird.
It's only showing up.
Hold on, let me try this again.
What the heck?
Hey!
I made it big.
whatever it doesn't wait why doesn't it not show up I'm so
confused whatever you can see it here yay all 50 started
with a short hike and then we oh my gosh Indiana Jones and
me side I forgot me side was last year I did Devil May Cry 3
Lizard.
Lifeline.
Oh, I can't believe we finished it a couple days after
Valentine's Day.
Henry Stickman.
Transformers, Devastation.
Metal Gear Solid 4.
Eh, keep surviving.
That was fun one too.
Super liminal.
Devil May Cry.
Peace Walker.
Dredge.
You really locked in in the back half of the year i think it
was when i was like you know what i'm gonna i'm going to do
50 games this year is when then i was like okay time to lock
in everybody
oh we did ground zeros nancy drew visage with doki half life
double make cry five duck detective i miss i love the
varying amounts of difficulty in these games there are
Some of them are like Devil May Cry and then it's like Blade
Runner
Jurassic Park Arcade Arcade Some of these are a bit of a
stretch but whatever
Oh yeah I loved Blade Runner It was so funny
Kirby I gotta play more Kirby games, especially because I
want to go to the Kirby Cafe.
Emissary Zero, that was a collapse, then we did that.
Blade Runner.
Jurassic Park, Lone Shark.
Some of these are like indie games.
Resident Evil 6.
Half-Life Tool.
Delta.
Metal Gear Delta.
Walking Dead.
Mystery of the Druids.
Oh wait, hold on.
It's going to disappear for a second.
Oh, ducky!
Get gifted in love, dummy.
Will this even show up after the backlog?
Of course it will!
Let's see.
Uh, duck walking dead.
Lego Indiana Jones, mouthwashing, Harvester, Silent Hill F.
Nuby's number factory.
Which is funny that we included that one too.
Portal, thank goodness you're here to the moon journey.
Yeah, we like had the law.
Look at this!
You guys, look at December.
We had to lock in like crazy.
It was the rush.
It was me being like, I don't think I'm going to make it.
No DMC boss could beat Blade Runner's Bridge.
to the moon journey last report what remains of Edith Finch
Lego Island limbo missed untitled goose game a lot of these
are like one shot games and if they weren't one shot games I
made them one shot games Barry was like I can't believe you
beat crow country in one stream I didn't expect you to do
that.
She's like, it took me three streams.
And I was like, I had to lock in, girl.
I had to lock in.
Yeah, thank you to all the iBus who recommended so many
games for me to play in one stream.
I, um...
I don't think I'll do something similar next year because,
one, I don't want to feel so rushed with playing games.
challenge is that like for some of these I was just like oh
my gosh I have to beat it in one stream so I was like boom
boom boom boom boom I gotta do it you know like I couldn't
take my time so much because I was like I can't have every
stream being I mean I could have them all being seven hours
but you know at the same time oh I just kind of wanted to
see if I could live up to the challenge you know and I did
so yeah it was fun to do it for this year but I don't think
I'll do it again next year it wasn't that it stopped being
fun not for not at all but it was a bit of a challenge to be
like how do I say um to you know like I said there were some
games that I put off because I was like oh these will take a
couple streams and um I want to I need more that i can do in
one stream you know what i mean so
no i don't see jazz punk
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait no
freaking way
no way
oh my god we did 51 games in and you know i was just like
and if i my one of my goals that i put for this year was to
do mind sweeper if i beat what mind sweet i was just like
what if i beat freak or treat today and then awesome mind
sweeper today and that would be my 51st game i didn't even
need to that's so silly
of a month.
I was like, seriously, I was like, I am going to beat this
challenge.
And I don't, like I said, it wasn't, oops, my bad.
It wasn't like a, it wasn't like a, oh man, this challenge
is not becoming fun because it's more work.
I still got to play games that, like, limbo.
Limbo is something I've always wanted to try out.
Um, missed.
Missed.
Um, I always wanted to actually like beat it because, you
know, things like, and Untitled Goose Game.
Like, there were there and one shot i always wanted to try
out too so um there were a good number of things that were
like on my list for the eventual yeah all right thank you so
much for the pocketed oh jazz punk was november oh my bad i
didn't think that i okay whoops
19th thank you wait roll wait how do i enter row below
whatever there it is okay
uh jazz punk
clover pit is also not on here i thought i thought i did add
it
did i play myself
did i play myself Wait, this is so...
This is so anticlimactic.
Wait, this is so anticlimactic right now.
You guys, this is so lame.
Wait a second.
No.
No way.
I played my show.
Fifty-three since you played it.
Myself.
Fifty-two games for 52 weeks.
That is basically, yeah, that is a game a week, right?
Ooh, that's actually really good then.
Oh my god.
Oh, 52 games!
And this is like me, I thought I was being like kind of
critical too.
I was like, you know, this isn't even all the games that
we've played, you know?
Like there's even more games that I don't count for like
having endings and things like that, so I don't include them
on the list.
So, there's even more games that we played throughout the
year.
Yeah, Bloons, Liar Bar, Power Wash Simulator, Peak?
Yeah, I didn't include Peak.
So much gaming.
I might be a gamer.
Bilatro, yeah.
How's Blue Archive?
Blue Archive's great.
Still play it every day.
Yeah.
I might be a gamer.
What's your game of the year?
Of these?
Or just like in general?
I don't know.
Let me go to my channel and see.
Let's see.
What is my game of the year?
Trying to think of something that like really sticks out.
Hmm.
Um.
In general.
Of things that I've played.
Hmm.
Let's see...
Going through...
Maybe Mystery of the Druids.
Dredge?
I think it has to be dredge.
Dredge or Oblivion?
Both of those I got like super...
Super like obsessed with.
I loved dredge.
I really love dredge.
I think that is my Game of the Year is dredge.
I played it so much.
I forgot about E-Tina.
I never forget about E-Tina.
Wait, hold on.
This is not what I meant to put on.
This one also is so sad.
There we go.
Let's see what else I got on here.
Do you guys see my tweet?
If you didn't, I had a dream the other night where I was on
a date with Dante from Devil May Cry.
And we were, like, in New York or something.
We were, like, on some, like, street cafe in New York.
And I remember his legs.
He, like, did that thing where he, like, swiped his legs,
like, up onto the table.
And he, like, put them down really hard.
And he was, like, hey there sweet stuff and he was just like
he was like you know I might date you but I'm gonna also be
seeing some other women on the side and I was like
which just sounds so much like it
yeah he was like sweet cheeks so he said sweet something and
I was like whoa he was like I'm gonna be seeing some other
women on the side like I might be seeing some other women on
the side and so and so and so and so and so and so and so
it's not any and he was just like he's like whenever i feel
like coming back to you i will and i was like no why what is
happening right now
and uh i was like you know that's okay That's alright Yeah,
I don't think I'm good
Virgil would never He'd just leave you entirely It's true It
was so funny though I never thought that I would dream about
Dante Especially being on a date with Dante It was like And
my dream from what I remember It was like It started
mid-dream Or mid What's the word?
Mid-date.
So it's not even...
I don't even know how we got there or anything.
I fall asleep and I'm like...
Yeah, in media ray.
I was just like, I fall asleep.
I wake up in dream.
I'm on date with Dante.
What did you eat for dinner?
I have no idea.
It might have been the migraine.
The migraine might have done...
for me yeah
looking at everything from this year i had a fun time i had
a fun year i hope you guys did too gotta be pizza akiomi
akiomi akiomi akiomi did you finish all the dmc games no uh
there were some that there like dmc one and two i think i
did last year Yeah.
Roadrunner cartoons.
Even, it's so funny.
It's so funny because even if I don't have like a super
great experience playing a game itself, like Harvester.
Playing it like was fine.
But I always think of games and how much I reference them.
You know.
Phil, thank you so much for the 50 gifted.
Tribe Princess, thank you so much for the 5 gifted.
Thank you both.
Thank you.
You always were a kidder.
Like, I referenced Druid so much.
I referenced Metal Gear so much, obviously.
I referenced Harvester so much.
Like, those are the games that I will remember so much
because of how much I referenced them.
Weeks of fun, weeks of fun.
And then Half-Life, I referenced so much.
No, well, thank you so much for the 50s.
Thank you!
Booty shot!
I love that we just say weeks of fun, weeks of fun!
What was your favorite stream this year?
That's hard!
Wait, hold on, I'm gonna go through my channel again.
My favorite!
Part of me, I really like the Valentine's Day stream because
I just like doing those kinds of streams so much.
much.
Let's see what else.
Um,
there's a lot of collabs that I had a lot of fun with.
Burger bots was pretty fun.
With uh, Nimmy Limu Snuffy Doki.
Oh, let's see.
Peek with Moni, Kamimi and Mimi.
was fun.
I really like collabs because I feel like it's so fun.
Oh my god!
My Metal Gear figure unboxing was so...
That made me...
That one and making the puppets I think I had a lot of fun
with.
Despite the It's Pink Incident.
I think those two are my favorites.
And it's funny because They're both hand cam.
Yeah.
I'm glad I could give Nimmy her puppet.
I will be making more puppets in the future.
I was...
Oh, at my Jurassic Park arcade stream.
That was really fun, too.
But I was asked about maybe...
So there was a convention that...
does a like a charity auction and they asked if I would like
to be a part of the charity auction and it's usually like
it's like people's kind of personal items it's not supposed
to be like you know high-ticketed items or anything like
that but I I suggested making a puppet for the auction for
the charity auction And I thought about also maybe making,
like, you know, honestly, they're not so difficult to make.
So I feel like if I asked Steiner, we could do like a couple
times a year.
I could have like very, I mean, they would be like the most
limited slots ever.
For some handmade puppets.
Of like a few slots.
That's one thing I also want to do.
is uh I mean I don't I'm not super crafty but I do like
making hand made things so um one thing I would love that I
wish I could do but there's just too many of you guys is
like drawing my own like checky like like actually printing
my own and then drawing on it and then sending it to you
guys um but luckily we'll have the checky for the Denzetsu
Patreon on yeah like a deco checky there's too many of you
guys
everything would have to be super limited and then i would
feel so bad that only a few people can get them
so i do what i can in the ways that i can so but there's
that's more stuff that i I would like to do in 2026.
Yeah, yeah.
I bought that checkie binder today for that Patreon.
Thank you!
Yeah, just a couple more hours for the Densetsu.
Here, hold on.
Wait, can I...
Let's see.
What?
Sorry.
Setsu na pro.
Two
more hours.
What was that noise?
It was the game.
It was the freak-a-treat game.
Just a few more hours for the Tenetsu debut merch item so
you can get, like, the happy...
Ooh!
Happy!
It's so cute!
Look at the back, has the Danmaku.
Yokoa!
Thank you so much for the fight!
Get the thank you!
There's the can badges.
Ooh!
So cute!
acrylic stands which I think actually I love the way our
logo looks with the as the base like I think the colors look
so good with the acrylic stand these and the checkie albums
because we will be starting checkies for um for the patreon
monthly checkies and and if uh if I can do checkies as well
then maybe you could one day stick a checkie in there with
me and then of course the band oh my god you guys wait these
are just the heads you guys look at this look at this
headband you could fill it all the way with minto heads or
phoebe heads or vicky heads or all three of us heads yeah
there's also the merch from the maid cafe the one at asa
yoru also in the in here too Look at that.
If you like the OIMO art from Freaker Tree, you can also get
more OIMO art.
Okay, add over.
Add finished.
I was told that I should do one more final push for Densetsu
merch.
So I did it.
I did it.
Yes, yes, yes.
It would be a great...
Alright.
Setsuna.pro.
Den-Setsu.exe.
Debut merch.
Pre-order ends tonight.
There you go.
P. Hot dog.
Celebrating that I got a new job for the new year by giving
you a spiritual offering is a nice treat.
Sendah!
Congratulations!
Should we play Mind Sweeper?
Wait, let me zoom in.
Oh, wait.
Wait, what if I do this?
I don't want these randos here, though.
It's a little scuff, don't worry about it.
Sorry, though.
That works.
Guys, I've never beat Mind Sweeper before.
Three means that three things are touching, right?
would be bad.
And the one thing means one is touching, so that would be
bad.
Diagonals count too.
Yes.
So that's why it's three like this.
Right?
Oh, unless this is the diagonal.
Because it's a diagonal.
But what would be...
Oh, and then like that.
like that because then it's too oh wait but you don't know
this one because it could be too too
oh this is a three oh my god wait now hold on i'm rethinking
my whole afterlife decisions
after life decisions everybody
thank you thank you thank this guy eaten happy new year me
though thank you Many Aibu loving Minto Many Minto loving
and spoiling Aibu Takes away your silly self Keeping me sane
from school and work Years to another year Also, y'all Don't
say y'all Don't say y'all Happy booyah Love your musical
rendition Of the first three seasons of Breaking Bad on Let
me stream Thank you!
Breaking dad.
No, I didn't say that.
I didn't say that.
Okay, I'm gonna do a random one.
Wait, this one though is easy.
One, two, three, four.
Four is easy.
This one is awesome.
Right?
Oh,
what do you mean though?
That's five.
Yeah, because of the ones here.
Oh, but it might not be that diagonal, is what you guys are
saying.
But this is for sure.
Guys, I did four, and then I added an extra one because of
these wands.
I can count.
Gosh.
You now have five flags around four.
Oh, oh, so then it would say five.
I get why you're yelling at me.
I get it.
This one probably, though, right?
Oh, wait, no.
Because then it would say two.
So this one's safe.
This one's safe.
So then it would have to be this.
Oh, that is four.
Sorry, I didn't think of this one up here.
You're right.
This is hard.
Wait, but then it has to be this.
Because that's one, two, three, four.
And it has to be this one too, right?
Because it's all...
Wait, no.
That's two already touched.
So this one's safe.
Oh!
What a thrill I feel touching them.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna do a random one for funsies.
Where do you go from here though?
Playing with fire.
Where do I go from here though?
Like what would you do?
The ones?
Oh, this one.
One's on the outside corners.
This one.
Below the three is safe.
Which three?
Maybe you should start with a smaller map.
No.
This is the...
Mind Sweeper experience that I must beat.
Maximus, I'm Mimi, so welcome to Membyship.
Thank you!
I'm gonna do another free-for-all.
Oh my god, oh, wait.
Oh, I thought there was a timer.
But it's going up, not down.
Okay, good.
There's that three above the bottom right three.
This one?
Wait, one.
Two, three.
Right?
It has to be this, sir.
What else is it touching?
Oh, I just noticed this one over here.
Just kidding.
You're right.
That would be four.
Oh, my gosh.
I get so focused.
I get so tunnel visioned.
Thank you.
Speaking of the stickers, thanks for the Vemble ones.
I like my pink.
I saw your earbuds are so cute.
Thank you for printing out the stickers and using them.
Start with the one at the top But it could be either of
these It could be this one or this one How am I to know?
How am I to know?
This one, though It has to be this one because of this one
right here That one, it has to be It has to be It has to be
These rage baiting guys Actually, I'm just stupid It has to
be this one too And so then it has to be this one And so
this one's safe Because it's one, two, three Here we go
It's too scary Oh my gosh The next two are safe too.
What does that mean?
Like, here, here.
You can click more around the three.
I'm going to click right here.
Oh my god.
Wait, so it has to be this one.
Oh, that's the two.
That's the two.
Diagonal, diagonal.
Because you know the mines all over.
already?
I don't think I do.
Oh, wait!
You're right.
Uh, one, two, three.
Oh, my gosh, you guys, I'm doing it.
So close.
I'm gonna do the corners.
This is what I used to do as a kid.
Wow, okay.
And then I'm gonna do one in the middle.
Nice.
And then I'm gonna do another one another one another
one okay I'm gonna do the corners I'm
feeling good um
easy corner wait what is the strap what do you mean easy
corner ones how are you supposed to figure that out like how
the heck this is where fat man got his idea for sinking the
big shell one touching one block equals mine yeah but like
there's it's touching three so how what is the straw oh not
in the literal corners ah like that oh okay i see oh she's
like that yeah yeah so i can touch this
okay okay okay okay okay And like this.
So I could touch this.
Oh, I could touch this.
I could touch this.
Everything the light touches.
Oh, I'm starting to believe.
I'm starting to believe.
Yes.
Now, I'm scared.
Now, I've done all that I know.
Wait, no, I haven't.
I'm a liar.
Wait, so that means this is clear.
And then...
Four.
Four of them.
No fear, you got this.
Still fear.
Three of them.
Okay, okay, okay.
There's many more I can clear.
I'm trying.
I'm trying my best.
I'm doing my bestest.
How would you mean there's still so many?
Oh, like this one?
Wait, no.
Oh, I can clear this, right?
Oh, my God.
Look near the ones.
Look up, gamer.
What's up?
Oh, like this one.
The day.
Holy moly canoli.
Whoa.
Happy New Year, Mito.
Happy New Year, Setsunan.
Is this all?
Like this?
Like all of that?
It's like that?
Like that?
Is that the name of the game?
We're only down to 88 bombs!
One.
So this one must be also.
Right?
So one, two.
Yes.
And this one, too.
So this one.
Safe.
Corner ones?
Yeah.
Oh, here!
More corners!
You're right, you're right, you're right.
Wait, would it be...
Wait.
Is this one safe?
No.
Oh, wait.
I think this... No.
This one is bomb.
Oh!
Wait, but then this one will be touching three!
Is this one wrong?
Wait.
flag is wrong yeah so
you have a one touching two
but this one has to oh it could be oh wait why didn't this
one clear then if it's free if it's not so this one's free
I'm scared if I touch it here I go Here I go.
Here I go.
It was fine.
Safe.
85, 85, 85.
I'm gonna try and get the 50.
Holy cow.
Oh my god.
How do you guys play this?
It's scary.
Too scary for me.
Oh wait, no.
These are touching, just kidding.
I'm a liar.
Sorry, I was looking at the corners.
If you explode in the game, you explode for real.
I know, that's why I'm so scared.
Yeah, I cornered too hard.
I got too comfy.
Too comfy for real.
But this one's safe.
Chill.
Use the thermal goggles.
um this one's touching two safe oh three wait it's touching
three so safe holy cow holy cow holy cow holy cow safe oh my
gosh oh my god it's too scary It's too freaky It's too
freaky This one is a corner though I found a corner I found
a real genuine corner Everybody Hands Touching hands Oh
reaching out Touching me Touching you Sss
Safe.
Okay.
We have left the safe zone.
Safe.
Touch an eye, boo!
Da-do-do-sweet!
Caroline!
Bread, bread, bread!
Another corner one.
Oh, you're right.
Which means we are...
Wait, we are back in the safe.
Safe.
It was touching, was it?
Corner.
All right.
Mistakes are the best teachers.
Exactly, everybody.
to make mistakes to learn i have to make mistakes to grow
i'm gonna do one in the middle one
they didn't i didn't just graduate from mind sweeper school
today wait i messed up the joke i didn't graduate from mind
sweeper school last week i graduated today And if I
graduated, I mean, I started learning.
I just enrolled.
Great job on the job, Vito.
I'm going to strangle you.
I'm going to kill you.
With a capital K.
Not in Minecraft.
Happy New Year's, Mrs. Vito.
Happy New Year's, Mrs. Bonnie.
Bye!
Hello!
I'm learning Mind Sweeper.
If I graduated, she means exploded into a thousand small
chunks.
Luckily, when that happens to me, all my ectoplasm, all you
gotta do is just like mop me up and then put me in a bucket
and I will eventually get enough spiritual energy to...
To become me again.
I should have taken what I got I should have I should have
went with the big one okay we're gonna go with the big one
corner I've cornered I've been cornered
okay corner why
me to where why because I'm just a little silly do you have
a gift ready for when you explode yeah you want to see
Josh Bo, thank you so much for the fucking.
All right, mop me up, guys.
Mop me up.
Mop me up, please.
You guys think this is a joke?
I have no lower half.
I literally...
It's gone now.
You think this is a joke?
She's dead!
Always has.
been all right this one has to be this right yeah because
this is also one too okay okay okay
wait so then this one has to be wait am i no
no oh it's touching oh my god you guys i keep i get such
tunnel vision for one area i literally stop viewing
everything else.
I don't think I'm ever gonna graduate.
I'm never gonna make it through school.
I'm never gonna catch my breath.
Say goodbye to those who knew me.
Why was I a fool in school for cutting Jim?
Hope he doesn't say right to me.
God, I really wish I knew how to play Mind Sweeper.
Click the button.
You must be swift as the core.
Coursing river, push the button.
With all the knowledge of the numbers, push the button.
I'm scared.
I'm going to push something in the middle.
One.
Enrolling Girl DM Academy.
Honestly, isn't she like crazy good at Mind Sweeper?
Guys, what move should I make right now?
I'm stuck.
I don't know what to do.
How many safe spots at the moment?
Gotta guess.
I just have to guess?
Look down, gamer.
At three.
This?
Three on bottom is safe.
Which one?
The left three.
This is safe?
How do you even know?
There's the only one with...
Oh, it's not safe.
Oh, they're all bombs!
Oh, I see what you mean!
Oh, because it's touching all three of these spaces and
there's nothing here.
Ah!
I see, I see, I see, I see.
I see, Kurim.
So then this is safe.
Yes.
Amtrak, thank you!
That was big YouTube!
These aren't like, these aren't speed run times, are they?
Oh good, thank goodness.
Thank you, thank you for gifting the membership so it
blocked my time.
for the flag of the I don't think any of these people were
streaming though when they when they beat it in 50 seconds
because I'm talking I'm not caught I have
93 left you're on world record pace I think I am I think I
am I'm gonna do it I'm gonna press it oh I'm
gonna eat a Kodoro for good luck okay I'm still trapped
though
More safe ones below the bottom one.
Oh, you're right!
I'm not gonna choke.
Oh my god.
One, two.
One, two, three.
We did it.
Nice.
It's still scary, though, everybody.
Please.
You might think I'm brave, but I'm actually very afraid.
I'm actually very scared, though.
The two is also safe.
I think you guys don't realize how many numbers are on this
board you can solve the three at the top wait this one how
it could be any three of these the one next to it gives it
away but it could be either of these look
at them thank you don't just lurking don't mind me I don't
think you're lurking if you're Doing that.
That's advanced tactics.
You guys, I'm literally a kindergartner, okay?
Right of three is safe.
I'm trusting you, one guy.
How did you know?
Three touches only one bomb.
Wait, three touches one known bomb, one touches one bomb
yeah what why couldn't it be down here why couldn't the one
bomb that it's touching be here and
then oh i already got how arrogant about you thank you
regrets of fatigue completed thank you for the fatigue it's
amazing that you were able to accomplish that this year
bravo and sorry to tell you but i already ate spaghetti for
dinner so your schedule can't stop me
you I'll get you my my pretty okay so this one's safe oh
scary though wait why did I think that was safe actually I
think I just gambled I think I just gambled with my life
there everybody
Yippee Wait, so if I Put down 90 Of the flags Well, let me
go into the negatives Just in case I'm wrong I need to put
down more flags And redo my strategy
Wait, it really will That's crazy
they taught you that at Mind Sweeper Academy no they taught
me that in Yu-Gi-Oh trust in the heart of the sweep
you can flag the corner block on the lower middle two with a
flag above it
this one you're right you are so correct you were so you
were so correct You were so accurate.
Then this one is safe.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay.
Holy cannoli.
And then it has to be this one.
Right?
I wish a big chunk, I wish half the map would clear.
No?
Oh, because you're right, you're right, it's touching.
Sorry.
Then it's free.
YouTube or no I'm sorry I'm sorry
I summon all five parts of Exodia to clear the field for me
So true Holy cow Yeah me too
It's taking me I'm very slow but I'm understanding it I just
literally have to like look for like five seconds and be
like Like this one's safe But I have to very like, I have to
look for not even five seconds.
I have to look for like many seconds.
I'm learning, I'm learning though.
I really feel good that I'm learning.
The three is now a corner.
This one.
Oh, you're right.
So one, two, three.
Oh my gosh.
I wish that made it easier to go.
clear up stuff though there's
a one next to the lower middle two that's a corner this one
yes you're right because it's not touching that one so then
that one's one two three wait yes so this is safe oh so
scary plus one for the one we missed oopsies Thank you,
Dorgo!
Look at the ones.
I'm looking, I'm looking.
Oh!
This one too!
You're us!
Salty Zero, thank you!
Happy New Year, Vito!
Happy New Year!
Happy New Year.
And the corner.
What corner?
Which corner?
This is not a corner.
corner yet oh wait it is a corner oh yes oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god holy cow oh my gosh i'm so
scared oh i'm so scared chabar welcome to membership thank
you
I'm so scared that I am.
I'm observing.
What if it goes above 1000?
Oh, the two is a corner.
The dang.
Oh my gosh.
I wish it made it easier for me to click things up.
It maxes at 9.99.
Oh.
It won't like restart.
and make it seem like I've beaten it really quickly.
Which three is free?
Oh, this one!
One, two, three.
Okay.
I'm gonna click these three now.
This one is too scary!
It's free.
Trust.
Dang!
Scary.
that was the scariest moment of my afterlife we have one
tell me if I'm wrong one wait but then wait one one two
three is that correct correct dang we
have 84 slowly but surely wait so this is also good I'm
doubting my I'm doubting myself.
And so the ones are safe.
Oh,
wait.
Oh, I have to make a decision here.
It has to be this one is safe, right?
And this one is evil.
Wait, no, I'm a liar.
This one is this one and this one is safe.
I meant the other way around.
Because I'm sorry, I was looking at the tail.
Okay.
Then...
To beat the game, do you have to clear the board?
Like, say I just marked the correct bomb, but I never
touched that.
Would it still beat the game for me, or no?
You scared me.
You have to mark all the bombs.
You have to clear all tiles.
Mark every mine correctly.
Oh.
You can win without ever using flags.
That's two.
Hell no.
One, two, three.
Oh my gosh, we're almost to the 70s.
So this is safe.
This is safe.
No, it's not.
Wait.
This is safe, though.
This is not safe.
That is not safe at all.
That's not safe.
This is safe.
DIN.
It's still too scared though.
I'm still too spooked.
she's becoming a mind sweeper expert hold hold hold now
don't my head is expanding
the other ones next to the one with the mind mark to save
wait the other ones oh you're right this one then okay that
one also safe yes yes very good very good
doing sudoku while she mind sweeps because i don't
understand the sweeping of the minds and minecraft no no
it's i feel like it's so easy but it's so much concentration
yeah i have the basics down for sure sometimes i might slip
up i might make a whoopsie i might make a whoopsie what can
i clear out now though i have so many twos Oh, I can...
Wait, no.
This one is also safe.
Ding.
This one is safe.
This one must be bad.
Just gotta keep chunking away.
If I can beat it in an hour, then it'll be New Year's.
If I can feed it in one hour, it will be New Year's.
This one, then.
And this one, then.
Wait, which means this one is safe.
I'm getting hungry.
I'm going to make more pizza rolls before the next column.
to believe mid
try remembering the basics of minesweeper yes boss yes boss
this one is safe din four four is crazy we're in a dangerous
area use a chaff and then click as fast as you can what if i
crawl over the mines and collect them with my body I've
always wondered if if snake crawled over so many of these
mines and collected them would he look like a sea urchin
yeah probably I'm gonna choose the one comment that that
supports my claim I out of all the comments that have gone
through the chat I'm gonna pick the one that supports my
claim thank you so much for the redirect hello i'm learning
how to play mind sweeper right now
welcome welcome
okay so thank you for the gifted and doing good thank you
for the fun kentine thank you okay what move would you guys
make right now because i'm oh wait i can do this and i could
do this then
I can do this.
No.
What?
Yes, this one's safe.
Face now, I'm thinking where the fuck is it?
Yes.
But then, this one.
Then.
Oh my gosh, we're getting close to the middle where I did
the random one.
What if I did another random one right now?
What if I double down?
Boom, boom, boom, bing, mong, bing, mong.
Save.
This one has to be like this, right?
Because that's four.
Which means the three is all good, so this is save.
And two has to... No, just kidding.
That's touching this.
Oh, two is safe.
safe safe not safe not safe not safe
safe safe safe safe safe safe safe safe safe
Not safe.
Oh my goodness.
Guys, we're at 70.
We have reached the levels that we have never reached
before.
Safe.
Not safe.
Wait a second.
No, I messed up.
Oh, two, two, two, two.
Safe?
Safe.
What do you mean I locked?
It wasn't locked?
I knew, I knew.
It wasn't a gamble!
I used my thermal goggles!
That's how I knew!
Safe.
It's still too scary to do it though.
It's still way too scary.
Nice.
Psychomantis, exactly.
So, safe.
Safe.
Do you start to recognize the patterns, do you?
Is that what the...
Safe.
I'm getting scared.
Not safe.
Safe.
Eventually it clicks, does it?
I'm waiting for it to click?
I'm waiting for me to become a god.
I'm waiting to become a god Safe Holy
canoli Wow I'm afraid of the day I misclick Afraid of the
day I misclick you guys Oh geez Not safe but safe
And also Safe
Not safe One, two.
We wouldn't want to misclick.
Right?
Right, right, right.
You're almost at 50.
You're right, you're right.
Oh, yeah.
I'm going to, I think this is jinx me.
Safe.
Well, I think I might become addicted to this.
I think I might become addicted to this.
Safe.
Look at me starting.
I'm starting on expert.
or intermediate?
This has to be expert, right?
I'm starting on expert.
I don't even start on no baloney beginner.
No, no.
You'll catch me taking the tank in the big numbers.
She has 999 points.
Yeah, you're right.
You're right.
Wait.
This is safe.
Someone say yes.
It is safe.
I didn't I didn't mess up the flags, did I?
Someone say yes.
She's really good.
Holy cow.
So safe.
We're safe.
I'm getting hungry.
Oh.
Safe.
Not safe.
Don't, don't, don't, don't.
Safe.
Ha ha, ha, ha.
Not safe.
Oh, this is safe.
Safe.
Guys, look how much of the map we've cleared!
Not safe.
This is safe.
All of this are so safe.
Yeah.
Safe.
Wait, this is all safe.
Wait, one, two, three, four.
Safe.
Scary This must be not safe That means this is safe And then
this is safe This is safe And not safe You cleared up a good
Cleared a good chunk of it Keep it up I believe in it Guys
if I beat this before midnight That will be another 2025
goal I've completed.
Can you imagine?
That would be crazy, no.
Safe.
Safe!
Oh gosh, I'm so scared!
I'm so scared, I'm so scared!
Oh!
Clear.
Beep, peep.
No, it's safe.
Safe!
Five!
I've never seen five before.
Oh my gosh.
Whoa!
Whoa, maybe I am getting bigger.
Five!
I mean, not bigger.
Better.
Wait, I mean bigger, higher score.
That's what I meant to say.
I'm a growing girl you guys Oh my gosh This is safe then
One, two, three Safe Safe Do, do, do Safe Do, do, do, do,
do Safe
Do ghosts grow?
I wonder maybe if I like I try to watch how much of your
energy that I eat You know, like...
I mean...
Like, I've even been cutting back a bit.
Because, you know, I don't want to be like a chunky...
You know?
Not that it's bad or anything.
But you know...
Safe.
The...
Maybe, though, I won't get...
Maybe I won't get chubby though.
Maybe I'll grow tall or...
Maybe I'll just keep...
my legs will go stretch stretch stretch like that i don't
know i've never tried lanky minto yeah oh my gosh wait i
could join the basketball team
knee extension surgery it's not surgery not safe
this is not safe
Okay.
The Lakers need you.
Why did two of you say that?
I could do a three-point...
Shoot.
I could do it.
I've done a three-pointer before.
I could do it, I believe.
Guys, I'm too scared.
I'm frozen.
I'm frozen stiff.
I don't know what to do anymore.
finish it off I need pizza rolls safe oh this one is scaring
me because there's too much too many variable safe no safe
so that's five right there pizza
roll pizza roll I'm on a roll pizza roll Do you think this
one is safe?
Holy...
Wait!
Dun dun!
We made it past 50!
Which means a bum, bum, bum.
And which means a bum, bum, bum.
Which means this is a safe.
Holy cow.
Good thing you didn't do corners.
For real!
Guys, I don't think that's a viable strat.
I don't think you should do corners.
Maybe.
I don't think that's a good strat.
Safe.
Two floors?
Wait, there's three floors right here.
If there was a fourth floor, it would be so spooky.
You don't mind restarting lots.
I guess that's true.
It breaks 50-50s.
I think I saw a stat that said corners are more likely to be
bombs.
Oh.
Look at the ones.
Safe.
Another five, guys.
It's too much pressure.
One, two, three, four.
It has to be this, though.
Gasp
This is still one Wait One, two, three, four There we go
Wait, did it Did it?
Sorry Did it?
Did it?
Did it do the other four too?
One, two, three, four It did No way I'm Yu-Gi-Oh-ing it out
Guys, you guys, I can't stop Yu-Gi-Oh-ing out!
Wait, that's five.
One, two, wait.
Uh-oh, wait.
One, wait, one, two, three, four.
No, we're okay still, we're okay, right?
One, two, three, four.
We're okay still.
I'm good!
Okay, okay.
I thought someone said it's five.
Okay, we're good.
So then this is okay.
One, two, three, four.
But I can...
No, no, sorry.
I can't do the three.
Oh,
do the ones.
One.
And...
1.
I did it.
Clear the ones.
We cleared it.
We're clear.
Area sweeped.
I declare thumb war.
What comes after the 5, 6, 7, 8 of the thumb war?
1, 2, 3, 4.
I declare thumb war.
What do you do?
try to keep your thumb straight
I was I thought it was who do we appreciate I'm ignoring
every single one of you and you know why I'm ignoring you
save save okay now area has been sweeped.
Area is clear.
Which means I can do this too, right?
For this three, one, two, three.
Swipped.
Wait, what do you mean one more?
Which one, which, which other one is there?
Above the two.
Where's the more ones?
But I don't know this one yet.
Up there.
The one.
Underwear.
Oh, wait.
No.
Oh, this one.
Didn't.
Area has been swept.
For realsies now.
for real these now
holy cow don't do that to me why would you do that to me
wait why are you saying no wait what did i do i made a
mistake three has too many flags
this one
oh i see i see These two.
Oh, I see, I see, I see.
But it would...
Oh, it can be this one.
Wait, just the top one.
Wait, how do you...
How do you know?
It could be either, right?
The second...
This one...
The top one is safe.
I'm getting lost in the sauce a little bit.
I got lost in the sauce.
Thank you.
Thank you, everybody.
Whew, saved.
This one?
Not safe.
Only have 37 bombs left.
Holy cow.
And this one?
Not safe.
36 bombs.
Crisis averted.
We did it, guys.
The evil is defeated.
I have one hour.
As long as I beat this one, I will complete my goal.
Of beating Mind Sweeper in 2025.
There's another isolated three.
This one.
No, yes.
This one?
One, two, three.
That one?
I should start making that sound effect.
It sounds like an explosion.
One, two, three.
Oh, wait, I did it again.
That's scary me.
One, two, three, four.
Okay.
Another five.
Evil.
Okay, wait, this one.
Right?
One, two, three.
This is two.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh my gosh, one more hour until the new year!
I don't think I'm gonna nap before the collab, but I'm
feeling okay.
As long as I eat, I think I'll be alright.
Boop!
Oh my god, oh my god, okay.
Oh gosh.
You can brag about your win during the collab.
I bet no one else has ever beat Mind Sweeper.
Don't look at the scores down there.
They're task bots.
They don't count.
This one is okay.
It's so scary.
I'll never get over how scary this is.
This one is also...
Wait, this one's also okay.
Actually, nope.
Yeah, all of these are my alt accounts.
This one, okay.
This one, not safe.
So then this one is safe?
Yeah.
Wait, is this one safe?
That's too scary for me to click.
I'm just gonna leave it alone.
Oh, it hurts.
Oh, so scary.
Oh my god.
Okay.
This one's safe.
This one?
Safe.
Check the threes.
What threes?
The threes, knees.
And above?
Oh yes, and above.
Thank you.
This one's also safe.
Holy cow.
Everything is...
We still have 30 bombs left in so little...
So little slots.
It's kind of insanity.
I am afraid for you.
Yeah, I believe.
It gets harder.
Wait.
Oh, no, never mind.
I was about to do something stupid.
Oh, I don't know where to go from here.
This is safe.
One, two.
This is bad.
You could do the long line of twos.
I'm too scared.
I'm kind of doing only two.
Only the ones that I feel comfortable with.
Check around the road too.
Wait, not yet, not yet!
Not yet, not yet!
Boom.
Dadoom.
Okay.
Try clicking the one some versions auto clears.
The one?
Wait, what one?
My heart is beating fast.
Yeah, me too!
Okay, this one is definitely not good.
Mito's brain expanding before our eyes.
I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm getting smarter, mom.
This two is safe.
I say things out loud, but I don't believe them.
This one is safe.
Two, do I go, thank you.
Mito grew three sizes that day, talking about your mind
sweeping.
Gotta hear it to decide if it's true.
Yeah, exactly.
This one, it's safe.
Oh, round here, though, also.
The three is full of mines.
There's threes everywhere.
I don't know which one you're talking about.
Safe.
And safe.
It's going to be devastating if we end with a 50-50.
If we end with a 50-50, that'll just be the way.
Spoiler alert.
Threes are red.
This one?
Safe.
Oh, God.
I didn't believe myself.
One.
One, two, three.
Lupine, that is me too.
Like the fingers over my eyes.
I'm just like...
I can't look.
It's too scary.
Okay.
We're closing in.
The two near the four is safe.
This...
What?
Oh, this one is safe.
Not safe.
But then also, safe.
Have we tried clicking the gray tiles?
Yeah, I'm doing it, I'm doing it.
You can figure out the top right twos.
This?
These twos here?
Places without minds are safe.
Where's my mind detector?
Am I a dog?
Oh, wait.
This is not safe.
Which means this.
Six!
One, two, three, four, five, six.
Oh!
One, two, three, four.
Safe.
We're going...
You guys remember when I said I want to get to fifth?
We're almost at 20!
These are safe.
Because one, two.
I clicked them so fast.
Okay, we're closing in, everybody.
We're closing in.
I have 50 minutes to beat this.
I don't know if I'll beat it in 50 minutes, even though we
only have 21 left.
I'm not ready for the line of two, you guys.
I don't know yet.
You say I can beat the line of twos, I don't understand.
I don't know.
Like, you know, I don't see what you guys are saying.
I'm not seeing at all what you guys are saying.
This one has to be.
Because 2-2.
I see it.
Which means...
This one is safe.
Okay.
To this one.
Like that.
Okay, okay.
Okay, which means...
These are all safe then, no?
All three of these?
Wait, no?
Oh, you're right, you're right.
Just kidding.
I see it, I see it.
But then that means this is safe.
I'm stressed out.
I'm stressed.
I'm stressing even more.
I'm the stressedest.
I'm stressed.
Just out.
One, two, three.
This is safe.
All three of these are safe.
Oh, wait.
One, two, three, so it's safe.
Oh my god.
So, one, two, three, four.
Okay.
All right.
We're making progress.
We're making good progress, everybody.
We're making good progress.
This is safe.
One, two, three, safe.
My scariest thing is if I place a thing wrong, a flag wrong,
and so I say one, two, three, safe, but it's not actually
safe.
Then who was fallen?
One, two, three.
That's the thrill.
I think I'm too scared now.
I was having a good old time when it was nice and full.
I mean nice and empty, but now I'm scared.
Not a very pro gamer.
Welcome to Membushhip.
Thank you.
Yeah, scared if you misclick something.
Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
One, two.
This must be one.
Come on.
Now I just have to decide which one is the scariest.
one here uh this one is the scary one and this one is clean
oh my god
one two three that's one two three four which means these
two are safe right No.
Wait.
Wrong.
What did I do wrong?
Oh.
Oh, wait.
This is the one I just did, right?
So, one, two.
Oh, I missed this one.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
So, this one is safe.
And then it's these two.
Or no.
One.
It has to be only one.
Wait.
Safe.
One.
Let's see.
Okay.
Time to do math.
Maybe.
It's this one.
safe one last corner oh my gosh this is safe because one two
three okay one two three four six okay slow and steady Minto
yes yes slow and steady slow and steady is honestly, I mean,
is saving me, so I would have died a long time ago.
I would have died so long ago, I think, but but we're okay.
We're fine-ish.
A win is a win, maybe.
You're a suit.
Dodeca, thank you!
Happy New Year!
It's nice to see you learn the ropes, Gumbare.
For hardcore puzzle enthusiasts, there is a brilliant game
called 19 Mind Sweeper variants on Steam.
Thank you for raising Mind Sweeper awareness.
Of course!
Of course, of course!
You're a suit.
Okay, hold on.
I'm trying to find any sort of rope that I can grasp onto.
Wait!
One, two.
This one is safe.
Watch me one, two.
Yeah, buddy, yeah, buddy, yeah, buddy.
Yeah, buddy, yeah, buddy.
Wait, I have to guess?
Wait, what do you mean I'm down to guessing?
Wait, what do you mean I have to guess?
Above four is danger.
Four is danger.
I have to guess.
You have to take a guess now to advance
I'm looking around I'm grasping at straws
Be strong, Minto
Two more flags above the top five How do you know though?
This?
How do you know?
Right here?
Wait, but one...
No, it's two.
many wait oh wait wait but
how do you know it's not the wait huh those top two are
confirmed but how I don't know how I don't know how they're
confirmed because
of the bottom five who because the last mine is shared oh
okay okay okay oh so it's either it has to be this one or
this one or this one oh my gosh you guys are applying really
big brain logic here
okay well we got rid of some i'll take it
now it's time for 50 50
hold on i need some like i need some like music here the
song is called thinking time I
can't take it seriously I'm scared
we praise everybody we praise I need only Minto pray emotes
if you have member ship and other and regular praying if you
don't have a membership even
though smiley face is like oh here I go three two
we manifested we manifested
um can I do anything with that
What did that do though?
Um, it wasn't a bomb?
Uh...
Yeah, we didn't die?
What is this song?
It's awesome?
It's from Dova Syndrome.
It's called Thinking Time.
Alright, there we go.
We did not die.
I'm scared though.
How do I work with this?
I think I have to guess again, no?
Top of two is a mine.
I thought that.
But I know it's a shared mine.
But why couldn't it be this one, you know?
Because then it would share with the three.
So I don't want to quite just be like this is...
This is...
Right?
Like...
And then it could be like...
Well, I guess it can't be that if it were to that.
Right of top two is a mine.
Really?
This one?
4 wouldn't work Wait, what do you mean 4 wouldn't work?
Must be a mine that shares the other two spaces With a 3
That only has one undiscovered
Okay I think I get it So it could be like this one and this
one Or like this one and this one And then this one or
something I think it takes me a second to...
I get it, but I don't get it at the same time.
Like, I get it, but I don't get it.
Oh my god, I only have 30...
35 minutes, you guys!
It's really hard to visualize.
Yeah, yeah.
These are advanced strats.
I don't get it.
Do I have to guess again?
You gotta guess near a 4 or a 5.
Yeah.
4's top right is safe.
This one?
How do you know?
No guessing yet.
Wait, where?
How do you calculate that?
Because of the 2?
These are too advanced for me, everybody.
I'm gonna click it!
I'm gonna click right here!
I'm sad.
My brain is like seriously like frizzing out.
Okay, I'm going to click this one right here.
Whoa!
So then one, two, three.
I
don't know how you guys did that.
I have no idea how you guys did that.
three, four, one, two, one.
This one is also safe.
Safe.
I'm relying on you guys like hardcore.
One, two, three, so safe.
One, two, three, four, five, safe.
Um...
One, two, three...
One, two, three, four...
Uh...
Oh, this one is also clear.
One, two...
Oh my god, I almost left click right...
Wait, not... No, just kidding.
There we go.
Okay.
I caught myself!
I caught it!
I'm...
One, two, three, four, five.
Okay.
Two, four, corner...
Oh?
There's two, four, corner two.
Whoa.
Okay, hold on.
Uh...
Oh, this one is... There we go.
Okay, so yes.
Okay.
One, two, three, four!
So this one is Boom.
If not boom, as in a bomb going off.
Just to be, just to clarify.
It's, it's, it's, okay, we have just seven left.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, our board has abs.
Directly right.
of two is safe.
This one?
This?
How do you know?
Someone, please explain.
Because of the two ones above it.
Oh!
Oh, because it would be sharing here and then if it were
this one, it would have to be sharing there.
Or...
This one's a bit harder to explain.
Just trust.
Yeah, I got I think I understood.
It's difficult.
It's still hard for me to visualize, but I think I
understood.
I think so.
It's hard.
This is hard.
I'm going to go play Meow Tower right after this, so I feel
smart again.
I'm going to play Meow Tower.
We only have 30 minutes, you guys.
Oh my gosh.
I'm starting to get a migraine again.
I need to eat.
Do you guys mind if I Wait, no, but I have to cook it
myself.
I'm gonna go get some water real quick.
I'll be right back.
Let me get some water.
And I'm gonna heat up my oven.
I'll be right back.
Okay.
Welcome back.
Tadaima!
It's guessing time again.
Is it guessing time again?
Area near 4, 5, 5 should be solvable.
Should it?
1, 2, 3, 4.
I don't know where else to put a thing, though.
Like...
And then...
1, 2, 3, 4.
Just one of these.
Yeah.
Not solvable.
No.
I'm too scared.
Above two should be safe.
How do we know that though?
We don't.
From vibes, all vibes.
Do you think I should just hit in the middle?
Like that?
I don't know what to do.
Honestly, my head is starting to hurt so bad again.
So I really need to stop thinking.
I might need you guys to hand hold me all the way through.
Because I can't take a medicine until I can eat.
On top of three is bomb.
Is this true?
I'll mark it.
Maybe.
We don't know.
It's a guess.
I'm guessing everything.
I'm getting so many responses from everybody in the chat.
I don't know what I want to believe anymore.
I'm gonna try maybe a cough drop will help.
I thought my migraine went away.
Why is it coming back?
Debs in chat?
I'm gonna do this one randomly.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna do it!
Crazy.
Yeah, it doesn't change anything, I think, but...
Honestly, the probability is better of just like, 1, 2, 3,
4, 2, 4, 6, 8, 10, 12, 14, 16, 18, 20.
With seven bombs?
I mean, the odds are in my favor.
Top right corner should be safe.
Which 50-50 spot would be good?
Like, uh...
Below three is safe.
50-50 by the fives.
What, like, one of these spots?
We're out a little.
I love when everybody just answers yes or no.
And I'm like, I don't know what you're talking about.
I'm gonna do below this three.
Here I go.
Moment of truth.
usable.
We have one.
I have 20 minutes.
Below the other three is safe.
This one?
Oh gosh, okay.
We can logic again.
Solve the two.
Boom!
Uh, I'm...
Not boom!
Boom!
Five left!
Bam,
bam, bam, bam.
Uh...
Alright, one, two, uh...
One, two...
Okay, hold on.
The three...
Wait, oh, that's it?
Guess between the twos?
Oh, man.
Ugh...
Which three am I going below?
There's two threes that I can go below.
What are you saying?
The lower three.
This one?
I'd say, though, this was a pretty good...
Pretty solid attempt for my first time ever playing Mind
Sweeper.
A lot of people were telling me below this three, though.
Earlier.
Shit.
Okay, I'm going to go hope that this guy...
goes away before my collab.
But thank you guys for helping me with Mind Sweet, but maybe
I won't.
It's not a, it's not a, what's the word?
Hold on, I'm gonna change the, it's this one.
Oh, that's so awkward.
That's fine.
I just picked a song.
But it's okay, we party.
Thank you guys for helping me with my first time ever
playing Mind Sweeper.
I'm sorry I can't count down with you right now.
But I will be there for the other countdown, so.
I'll be there for the next countdown.
So sorry, EST.
Just pretend.
Let's just pretend, okay?
Get right, go away, clock.
Go away.
Three, two, one.
Happy New Year!
Just play this right before...
Wait, no, we're pretending.
We're a happy New Year!
Thank you, guys!
And if you are PST, then we will celebrate that countdown
together, hopefully, if I can stay the whole time.
Happy New Year, East Coast, happy New Year, Europe.
That was a while ago, though.
And I guess Asia has been in it, too, for a while.
2026 Thank you Thank you thank you Yeah in Australia Yeah
yeah Thank you thank you I'm gonna go eat before the next
collab But I will see you then Bye bye Otavito